ainsi leur sang progresser la poule c il
va couler donc le journal a duré trois
jours donc à 13 secondes dont une eau à
438,5 à cap s'intéresse à voilà et
certains actionnaires moi il me semble
que
deux mouvements les rues seront aussi
importants que à huy le plateau et
muscle c'est ça qui est vraiment hyper
excitant qui intervient juste après le
vrai champion du monde en partie lente
du coup bah c'est top nani est vraiment
hyper hyper intéressant est ce que
craint cette va confirmer ou non y est
c'est là donc
les titres gagnés
tout à fait il est double tenant du
titre et du coup c'est assez intéressant
de voir ce que maintenant on voit que
nakamura il est vraiment tout présent
sur sur internet et est-ce que
quinssaines va être va être devant là ça
va être ça va être hyper intéressant
parce que c'est quand même une cadence
qui amène beaucoup plus de variance à le
rapide on ne sait donc ça va être très
chaud très chaud c'est un gars alors
qu'à moi il n'y a
parfois qu'un seul avec deux ans
c'est toujours un peu particulier et
puis en plus sur internet tu as moins de
pression du résultat des tournois il en
fait plein on va toujours su refaire un
moment là on sait que l'impact est
beaucoup plus gros même si à 13 ronde ça
peut vite ça peut vite des gones est ce
genre de tournoi même pour des joueurs
aussi
c'est possible sign qui me paraît
ahurissant et du match et du coup je
vais aller mettre mon casque je voulais
pas de m je me fais pas de soucis 1
c'est pas grave
on s'adapte on s'adapte on espère que je
suis pas chez moi aujourd'hui je suis
j'ai un ami qui m'a prêté son
appartement pour pouvoir s'entraîner
parce qu'il a un super ordi et tout ça
et du coup eh ben je vais devoir
adapter et adapter le maître mot le
maître mot du commentateur se trouve
certes la natation adaptation
est ce que tu m'entends
moi je t'en ferons toujours sans toit
toujours j'ai vraiment aucun problème
pour salut à toi super look ligne
pour l'instant assez d'un petit pré
passé l'entâme celle entame c'est ça
le casque
méthode ça marche pas
voilà bah y avoir du monde donc bien sûr
on n'a pas forcément dit mais il ya les
deux championnats il y aura aussi le
championnat féminin de parties rapides
et ce qui est assez cocasse d'ailleurs
je sais pas trop pourquoi j'ai pas
l'explication et j'espère que stéphane
pour la donner attention je vais
peut-être prendre au piège avec avec
cette question mais j'ai constaté qu'ils
avaient il y avait onze secondes chez
les femmes et 13 secondes chez les
hommes je vois à trop de l'explication
pour être tout à fait franc et je trouve
même dommage que ce soit pas tournoi
mixte voilà je veux beaucoup de choses
je veux refaire les règles de ce
championnat et j'aimerais bien on a vu
dans le récent jeu pas de france des
jeunes des jeunes filles faire la
compétition mixte puisqu'il n'y avait
pas de championne d'europe et je pas du
monde donc ce n'est pas forcément des
championnats nationaux qualificatifs
là on arrive aux championnats du monde
ça serait super pour moi que ce soit
mixte pour mêler les femmes aux hommes
et je pense que ça amènerait une
progression naturelle du niveau des
échecs tels n'a à l'échelle mondiale ça
me plairait en tout cas de voir un petit
peu bad et des jeunes femmes comme
gorillaz qui n'a et autres peut-être que
serait plus incitatif pour que les
meilleures joueuses mondiales sera tout
présente même si la majorité d'entre
elles sont sont là en tout cas c'est ce
que c'est ce que j'aimerais
en titre le staff est venu pour m'aider
à régler le gaz a comme que royal at il
ya de la technique exactement ce que je
comprends pas pourquoi ça marche pas en
quelques secondes le sud de retour chez
vous ouais ça gagne c'est un gangsta
c'est bien tu fumes est donc douze et
quinze secondes mais c'est quoi la
raison en fait
je pense que
ouais donc plus de rondes ok pourquoi
pas ça c'est un argument en tout cas moi
je ne vois pas trop pourquoi pourquoi on
n'est pas tout le monde ensemble j'ai
bien vu un peu c'était c'était des
comics pour pour l'ensemble mais je vois
je vois pas trop je dois vous arrive
sauf par contre ça ne convainc pas si
vous voulez voilà
donc la technique sera éclatée mis ce
rêve ne vous inquiétez pas
on tourne en tout cas voilà quant au
retour de tout faux en france voilà tout
je pense qu'il est là où il est il a
l'air il parlait des moustiques et de la
chaleur je peux vous dire que pour ma
part je suis en bretagne et il ya moins
de moustiques et et mois de chaleur
pour l'instant il ya pas photo il a
l'air
ok ok de brasse et c'est un argument
c'est ce qu'on dit aussi dans certains
cas pour éviter qu'ils aient
et au championnat national par exemple
ce genre de problème avec toutes les
femmes en moi je sais pas je suis pas
sûr quand même que j'en ai pas qui se
distingue comme ses passages pas
franchement c'est un peu le même
principe même si on voit que le niveau
n'est pas très clairement mais si on
veut voir les échecs féminin progressé à
un moment il va falloir surtout dans des
compositions comme celle là de rapides
et de et de blitz bas favoriser sa voilà
à mon sens tout cas
j'ai pu très facilement brodé sur un
sujet donc on parlait de il ya un
tournoi mixte et avait fait mine 1
est-ce qu'on peut pas faire qu'un
tournoi mixte stouff pour doper le
niveau des échecs féminin avec mon
honneur qui manquent il y aurait
peut-être beaucoup trop de femmes en bas
de classement ça ferait pas bonne presse
ça c'est pourquoi pas c'est un argument
très clairement mais
comprendre sa polarité et il est vrai
que les femmes moins forte les allemands
et même pour l'initier de manière
générale on aura plutôt qu'un autre
pourquoi elle s'est parée tu vois donc
je marche qui court pour faire un
exemple nobel
oui oui en fait j'ai pas compris c'est
apparemment se plaint toujours du son
ouais
c'est moi je sais qu'à titre personnel
je pense que je pense que ça va donc ça
d'où ça vient peut-être de toi je sais
je sais pas je sais pas trop
si si le technicien pas un essai c'est
toujours gelée de pomme j'ai essayé sur
je le mets mais
peut-être content par une double sortie
c'est possible
c'est à dire
ok c'est parfait chez toi cabine
merci
faut que tu le désactive à un truc
je pensais pas merci matouk matouk
atteint tu es en train de me dire que
j'avais bon techniquement sur quelque
chose apparemment c'est une double
sortie c'est sûr c'est rare que je fasse
une remarque pertinente techniquement ça
me fait vraiment plaisir et robin 5
confirme malheureusement donné toi je
trouve à part par te dire ce genre de
choses je vois je te laisse te laisse en
plan ce que je peux pas je peux pas
régler à 10 ans est-ce que là ça va
mieux ou pas
je pense que j'ai acheté en donnant
toujours pareil on peut mais je crois
que trouvé l'astuce je pense que là ça
doit aller mieux les gars de fria du
technicien dans le chat est oui a
vraiment subi et il ya sûrement d'être
désolé hqe en fait là je suis venu que
ma maison chez mon ami j'ai dû tout
réinstaller tous les ordis le sont les
caméras les les casques les micros j'ai
dû tout réinstaller et puis ce matin en
plus j'avais pas encore les tous les
temps plein sous les trucs pour tess
comme c'est un petit peu là la foire ce
matin et enfin ce matin en fait chez moi
chez moi martina il est 11 heures du
matin et bien qu'il ait peut-être ça les
gens oublient d'être 7 heures du matin
je suis en train de régler tout ça donc
donc donc ça a l'air de bien marcher
maintenant donc tout nickel est toujours
bien stéphane de commencer comme ça tu
commences modestement et puis après
c'est parti c'est une stratégie je
pensais que ça après les prochains jours
genre demain après demain je pense que
j'ai tout laissé branché je
prends pas de risques donc on voit sur
les camatte ça a commencé en tout cas
chez les femmes oui on a entraperçu
katarina l'agglo s'asseoir et donc du
coup je vais actualiser un peu mon
échiquier pour voir si jamais c'est un
jeu chez carlson donc on a plusieurs
caméras et envoyée aujourd'hui
donc j'ai aimé un peu ma caméra chez les
femmes parce que les hommes n'était pas
encore installé on voit deux car c'est
l'état ça a commencé
commencés est lui aussi alors je veux
voir si du coup il ya moyen de la caméra
qui s'enlève un tu as les kanak sont pas
encore exactement prête c'est un
problème s'appelle soit on a entraperçu
magnus à un moment c'est un problème
technique session sur pièces comme
malheureusement ou enfin sur les caméras
de la fidh ouais ça va venir s'arrachent
les caméras fixes sont pas encore sont
pas encore totalement
c'est
est ce qu'on peut pour l'instant voir
voir la partie de magnus on va la voir
et pour l'instant ce sont les scores il
n'y a rien qui lancé tu vois je
ashkénaze et la partie il faut deviner
le début donc 2 gb de mettre la caméra
de grappes saines alors je vais
revisiter laquelle ces caméras est la
mieux pour voir car le ciel mais
effectivement c'est
[Musique]
les caméras ne sont pas très très bien
fixer ce que je vois
bon ça va se régler un peu de patience
et cameron sont 400 nl et elle n'est pas
allée pas terrible je vais vous la
mettre quand même là on la voit dévoile
un peu des fois elle saute et pour son
adversaire c'est un encore un peu moins
bien ouais assez bon allez on voit un ça
y est on voit que tu es comme a enfin
actualiser la partie dont 4/5 savoir en
échec et je crois qu'on va les voir et
de la bouger
s'organise pas avez raison c'est bien
c'est bien une espagnole c'est un
espagnol sur la partie alors j'étais de
changer de la caf la caméra vu que
la bouteille de 6 kg et c'est pas
forcément optimales
devrait être mieux
bas effectivement autant réaction de
monsieur à mixer l'échiquier qui compte
le plus plus que la cam mais c'est vrai
qu'en partie rapide particulièrement on
voir les émotions ça peut être des fois
c'est marrant quand même
parce qu'il peut se passer des drames
beaucoup plus qu'en partie lente et du
coup si on les a en direct je pense
qu'on va on va passer des bons moments
quand même
yes non c'est clair vont voir voir la
partie bien sûr c'est le plus important
qu'on veut voir tu es ensuite par contre
c'est d'avoir les caméras c'est quand
même ça parce que ben on voit les
joueurs on voit la réaction voilà un peu
leurs mimiques et tout ce qui se passe
et c'est vrai que c'est c'est hyper
intéressant et ça c'est l'héritage qu'on
a aujourd'hui avec caméra qu'on a et
c'est vraiment super intéressant fou des
deux jeux par 47 voix sur la caméra
bien des fous des deux donc ouais c'est
les espagnols ba com - bull et enfin
dans le style de lentilles marcheurs
avec à 4 qu'on a vu pendant championnat
du monde des espagnols ultra
positionnelle où on a un jeu de pièces
un peu plus agréable que la torah par
exemple par rapport à la tour b 8 et du
coup bas il n'y a pas de prise de risque
avec les blancs magnus toute façon il
est beaucoup plus fort que son
adversaire son adversaire et grand
maître c'est un petit grand maître du
coup il a juste envie de jouer aux
échecs quelque chose d'assez simple et
de faire la différence pestait
donc la tour 8 a été le para ghana
chevelu donc on peut imaginer peut être
un plan d'action ou réfuter faut aussi
ce qui est typique ans position pour
récepteurs de le d5
généralement la torre mans après trois
buts un plan qui est assez connu que le
maître le fou 1 6% chez les fous et il
est dépourvu de mètres pour récupérer
avec avec la tour 11,6 et aussi défend
le pion aux 5 parce que dans beaucoup de
moments et ben ont ajouté 5 et aidera
oui c'est pas les six gars lisez
sauf sauf comment dirais-je
qu'il y aura cavaliers des 5 parce que
c'est l'idée d'avoir mille cavaliers en
c3
et du coup c'est pas si facile de mettre
le la poussée des seins en place oui
paquet nocar prof c'est un petit grand
maître par rapport à magnus carlsen si
vous voulez ça je l' ai déjà dit pour
moi tous les 100 points il devrait y
avoir des sortes de dan comme au judo
c'est à dire que 2500 ces grands maîtres
de mission 6 ans c'est super grand
maître de 1700 super super grand maître
et 2800 ses élites mondiales donc ça
aurait du sens pour moi puisque je fait
le distinguo entre battre un grand
maître battre un grand maître à 2600 ses
amis saveur bien sûr chacun reste à sa
place j'aimerais bien
j'aimerais bien avoir le niveau 2 de
roubaix nashville y a pas de sous pas de
souci là-dessus un foret faut rester à
sa place mais effectivement ce ne sont
pas les mêmes catégories de joueurs même
s'ils sont s'ils ont tous les deux le
titre de grand maître à jouer parce que
tu en penses tu es fan je suis d'accord
avec toi c'est un grand maître à 2400
euros 1 euro mais devant être à 2650
lots c'est pas la même chose et donc la
banque et qu'elle ne l'a fait il a 25 40
1 c'est pas
c'est pas une patate ce pain blanc n'en
pleure c'est pas mais bon karl scène
quoi ils ont le même titre tous les deux
alors que ganev champion du monde et
l'autre qui justin un grand match
standard donc c'est vrai oui c'est ce
que je pense des paliers comme tu l'as
bien indien je pense trouver dan c'est
pas mal ça résume pas mal ce que tu
disais et
samassa mali
oui parce qu'il ya moins d'écart entre
google budaj chili et nous quand
qu'entre gouverna julie et qu'arsène
c'est juste pour schématiser les choses
donc bon on va pas se mentir l'écart est
phénoménal même s'il porte ce joueur
géorgien le titre de grand maître
chez les français
oui parce que pour l'instant il se passe
pas grand chose encore sur ses choix on
est dans une espagne tradi dans le temps
et se faire plaisir comment vos vertus
et et et stéphanie me semble que tu
voulais me composer un petit peu mais je
m'en a parlé avant le live mais tu me
lis un peu caché ouais c'est moi je
pense que je vais rebondir sur ta
proposition parce que chaque thébaux
mais chine va un petit peu pensez donc
je te laisse ma proposition et après je
maquille un peu les choses pour pas
perdre tout de suite ça marche alors du
coup bon ma première idée déjà on a deux
français dans ce championnat du monde
donc deux français un peu ce qu'ils sont
capables de faire chacun de beaux
exploits et même rêver d'un titre
mondial donc on pourrait bien sûr de
gagner on parle bien sûr de maxime
gingras donc mvl et de là
grande star montante allez allez les
affaires aux là et du coup je voulais
trouver un petit pari comme ça sans
choisir je te laisse choisir est-ce que
parmi les deux joueurs tueur est un
joueur que tu voudrais soutenir et est
ce que tu voudrais qu'on fasse un petit
pari pour savoir lequel va arriver
devant l'autre
qui donnera vide la cadence haussière du
monde de rapides il ya sept ans mais
kana c'était de rechange aux caméras ok
bah moi je joue ouais je je vais réagir
en fait fuir ou de ja pour l'instant
même si l'arrivée en france on connaît
assez mal enfin on le connaît à
l'échelle mondiale mais mais c'est vrai
que maxime vachier lagrave j'ai joué
trois fois contre lui de toute façon les
chocs proximité plus naturel pour le
moment j'ai je vais jouer pour pour la
personne que je connais et je vais jouer
donc pour maxime alors que firoud déjà
sur le papier c'est vraiment son type de
cadence en mai mais c'est vrai que
depuis on connaît maxime depuis très
longtemps donc ouais par
way habitudes et puis au delà de
l'amitié ouais c'est vrai que j'étais
j'ai envie de 2,2 de le soutenir dans ce
championnat alors que beaucoup vont
choisir la star montante donc je décide
de jouer un maximum ok ça marche
c'est moi très bien moi ce sont les deux
me vont très bien les deux sont hyper
intéressant à voir et à weave à chioggia
il a assis le flamboyant en plus il va
être servi son
potentiel en tout cas tous les deux on
espère qu'ils vont qu'ils fassent des
deux très beaux exploits
devant les caméras bug un peu
franchement la caméra car ce n'est de
bugs il ya celle là il a écouté devant
lui et l'autre caméra en fait qui
s'éteint toutes les deux minutes et 1
donc il faut qu'elle est donc un terrain
de caméras sur carrousel et j'ai pas de
caméra pour l'instant surfer rosa ni
maxime j'ai accès que quelques cas quel
de caméras et donc ça c'est les filles
soient cac40 scène pour l'instant ce qui
est assez marrant c'est que
maxime vachier lagrave et carlson ont
joué un petit peu
genre le début avec des espagnols des
trois presse a un petit peu changé y en
a un qui a joué pour a4 et l'autre pour
à trois cavaliers c3 mais on est dans le
même type de début sans rice et on va
travailler les grands maîtres bah pareil
hein
durabilit là j'espère que je prendrais
bien mais on voit que cela en corse et
c'est un grand maître de classe mondiale
mais pas de haut de tout premier plan et
du coup là encore ils veulent aller
travailler dans des positions assez
stratégique mais il faut qu'on fasse
gaffe qu'un petit peu à ce type de
joueurs parce que dura bailie moi je
l'avais joué beaucoup pas mal de
tournois online mais aussi des tourneurs
encore commence plus est rapide et il
est vrai que je pense que
ambühl s'est rapidement fin lui en tout
cas il est très dangereux je les ai vus
faire pas mal de père tu vois un petit
peu à la comment il s'appelle
j'ai peu son nom un jour l'europe et il
a un azéri
gpat roman en tête c'est un plus il ya
plusieurs jours à 0-2 1600 aylwin très
très bas mais d'offres
et à safari safari qui est connu pour
les services malin voilà abbas tough a
été citée par sagan ista et sinon
mamediarov on pourrait dire qu'il est
pas mal augmenté manière les gars qui
avaient 2006 en hausse
mais je voyais les géorgiens parce que
j'imagine que javaux bas c'est joe baba
et du coup là bas va servir
oui alors je ne le trouve pas photo ja
dans la liste alors j'en sais pas si je
sais c'est moi ou si c'est
en tout cas par action dans des petites
espagnol de tranquille ou alors je suis
d'accord avec toi sauf pour dire que sur
une partie en fait tout peut se passer
c'est à dire que ces grands maîtres ah
oui on a qualifié de deux petits
grand-mère est ou pas de grands maîtres
de premier plan etc ils sont hyper
dangereux sur une partie mais on les
voit pas gagner le tournoi en tout cas
je ne les vois pas gagner le tournoi
parce que c'est trop dur c'est trop dur
pour eux par contre peuvent battre
n'importe qui
jova bas effectivement et vous avez bien
écorchée jo bats pas pour l'instant ça
marche toujours pas et ils javaux bas
jova bas
on n'a toujours pas les lettres dans le
bonheur
tapez 33 mois mamede revin je vais pas
fair use je vois pas d'entendre
elle était pourtant annoncée
est on en est là dans la vie ce que
j'appelle problème à balladur voilà
ça s'approche ça passe ça s'approche
et du coup moins ce qu'on peut dire on a
fait un premier petit paris entre nous
doit leur faudra que l'intérêt je te
laisse je suis assez intéressé voilà
french est à corriger ces balladur
effectivement
alors moi il y avait un autre parent et
qui m'intéressait aussi des fans je te
laisserais voir un peu le reste je sais
que je suis ouvert à plus et paris
alors pour moi si tu veux il y avait
quand même
trois grands favoris
[Musique]
deux grands favoris pendant ces 15
scènes nakamura plus firoud job j'aurais
bien rajouté en favori aussi et moi ce
qui m'intéressait c'est justement qu'on
trouve un autre cider capable de gagner
ça me parait hyper intéressant est ce
qu'on peut faire un petit pari en
excluant justement nos joueurs français
et en excluant
nackaerts haine qui sont normalement les
deux plus forts joueurs sur ses cadences
là en tout cas c'est ce que je pense à
et etc ont choisi justement celui qui va
parmi ces quatre hors de ces quatre
joueurs le mieux figuré
parce que tatami des recettes en vain
bah moi en tête alors juste comme ça
faudrait que je regarde la liste des
amants mais il pensait à 12 heures déjà
parce que pas mal pas mal pas mal femme
albert duda des jabots la green room
journalistes il est bien au stéphane sur
la vistule a pas vu mais il est bien où
je peux dire que je les regardais
l'alarmé
quand il m'a expliqué laurent labat
france abou dhabi de la coupe du monde
la boîte richardson et en buts c'est
rapide
c'est quand même un joueur qui à bakaye
la taille du die là mais vous mettre sa
partie si vous voulez il a les blancs
ici dans cette position de la plus
animée la nissan versa
tout à fait en mémoire la structure
créée accès ristic de majorité centrale
contre majorité elle dame effectivement
et ben moi dans ce cas je te donne mon
joueur et j'espère qu'il est bien là
parce que j'avais regardé la liste mais
faudrait pas qu'ils aient de surprise
mais je voulais jouer n'est pas au match
parce que si tu veux pour moi il doit
être déjà elle joue très vite on a vu
alors qu'il ya pas mal de gars fait du
range pas du monde sur la fin de tournoi
mais je l'avais trouvé très
impressionnant au début de tournoi arrêt
s'est écroulé effectivement mais pour
moi c'est un outsider véritablement
ultra dangereux et qui doit avoir envie
de se refaire en fait et je me dis ça
serait énorme autant j'ai été surpris
par sa réaction pendant je fais du monde
où on le voyait complètement ailleurs et
pour un mec de ce niveau là c'était
étonnant même si le contexte est
particulier autant là je me dis qu'il
peut peut-être revenir et ça serait ça
serait tout juste incroyable s'il
arrivait à faire quelque chose dans ce
championnat donc j'avais ma petite idée
en tête
ok bah écoutes je pense que ces clauses
1 parce que
mes pots et n'est plus là c'est quand
même deux grosses à rillieux prétendait
aussi au titre mondial en blitz je pense
qu'ils sont sont largement capables de
faire le tournoi demain un bon tournoi
et gagner le championnat donc on avait
aussi levé sur carroll un chef qui je
pense incarner ans est moins fort en
blitz mais bon quand même pas eu quand
même un des meilleurs joueurs du monde
je pense qu'il est capable
d'apprécier rapide puisse pas doubler
tellement donc je pense que car ronaldo
sait capable de faire un tour du monde
qui on pouvait voir ma vue critchlow
dans les châteaux fritsch aux critères
proposés oui bien évidemment que tout ce
qui a déjà gagné d'ailleurs je peux à
demande blix une année
donc je pense que leurs rapports pour
moi rapport c'est un très très bon
joueur mais j'aime beaucoup voir se voir
dehors la commenter ensemble je crois le
match on l'a vu au speech s est
il a quand même un souper remet ça en
1200 fins temps blitz bullet
farine en plus ouais mais hyper décevant
dans la dent les enfants de partie c'est
sur internet exact mais même pour moi il
a un style de jeu qui qui fait qu'il
n'est pas forcément très
solide sur le long terme la pression
avec de dire oui c'est vrai - stable
maintenant bêta le flamboyant mais non
stable voile alors que 1,12 us ou 1 ou 1
ou 1
ou un dépôt c'est vrai que pour moi
c'est quand même plus basses plus
expérience dans le haut niveau et
je voyais plus ça comme ça
anish giri nous a été proposée juste
stéphane cic bien les fidéliser par
nakamura je crois dernièrement dans le
speech est sain
on n'en a pas parlé de guillery moi je
le vois pas gagner ce droit du monde
c'est non mais c'est mon avis voiliers
mais évidemment à égalité à bon compte
mais doit pas déjà perdu loin quand même
et aronian non plus alors qu'il ya
quelques années je te régule art hogan
je t'avais paris la maison j'aurais pas
de la maison d'ailleurs
mais aujourd'hui je le vois pas je ne
vois pas
demain on l'a vu on l'a vu l'autre fois
on savait pas trop s'il avait une bière
à la main pour jouer son speech s mais
en tout cas cela il a un truc le match
semblait passer ça
et ça s'était pas très bien passé pour
lui c'est un joueur exceptionnel quand
même c'est ce qu'ont relatait mais à
toute la nouvelle génération c'est pas
facile pour ces joueurs là parce que il
ya du monde qui arrive quoi oui mvl peut
gagner ça c'est clair amv lmv elle peut
gagner mais on n'a pas droit de parier
sur les français c'était la règle et là
ils sont les françaises 147 nakamura ben
moi je faisais duda et de choisy niveau
voilà donc ce niveau là oui donc là on a
une partie de ton plein après la partie
qu'on regarde si la partie 2-2 alors je
sais pas trop comment cependant mastro
vassilis donc un joueur grec va être à
de grands miracles qui joue contre eux
nepomniachi donc nepomniachi vice
champion du monde que j'aime pas trop à
plaindre
j'aime pas trop ce qui se passe pour les
peaux match et parce que même si il ya
un pion un pion de plus je trouve qu'il
ya une grosse pression
ah oui alors il peut s qui peut faire ce
qu'harry francis cavaliers f50 je pense
à ce qu'il veut faire sur ce cas vallée
prend ici les autres cavaliers f5 on va
analyser qu'avaient les f-5 attaque la
dame et en même temps attaque double sur
le cavalier et je défends aussi le matin
on a
donc comme la chine est en train de
mettre une pression incroyable
d'ailleurs autant
mastro vase mastro vasilis
car on voit qu'il a il a six minutes
contre 14 en fait il lui a troqué le
pion dans le début il est en train de
dire y'a pas assez et c'est vrai que ce
serait si ce casse un peu le foot est
roi et ont dit tout le temps stéphane
que dans les fous de couleurs opposées
faut rester très dynamique sur la
couleur bas noirs pour les blancs et
puisque ils ont le foot le foot 15 noirs
et là le coup et f6 de nespouls machi et
est vraiment bien vu parce qu'il ils
bloquent le fou ces trois tout
simplement ça on peut l'expliquer et
maintenant le jeu sur le roi noir est
moins facile à mettre en place
mais assez clair donc il ya des
problèmes sur le site m6 et c'est vrai
qu'il ya voilà comme je disais avec le
plan est bon et c'est un point je veux
dire toute façon sont déjà en jeu les
clones sont ouvertes et les pièces
noires sont un petit peu présente pas
très bien placé et puis c'est au noir
maintenant de faire de faire l'effort de
bien placer ses pièces sur la tension
s'est pas passé comme position à sa
série il n'y a pas le droit selon
moi je trouvais aussi un mais le coeff
si c'est bien vu et c'est vrai que
il se base sur une tactique si vous
voulez stratégiquement c'est malin et
et tac tic tac tic pour se permettre de
faire en fait ce coup m6 avec la petite
caravane f 5,6 ce qu'on a vu c'est ça
mais on va pouvoir aller voir les
français effectivement après alors pour
répondre à magnésium or pour l'instant
j'ai pas le g palais enfin on a parlé
français en caméra et sa caméra que j'ai
pendant ce carême et c'est je crois
cette première chéquier hommes et le pr
marché qui est femme qu'on peut voir
donc malheureusement si vous voulez les
caméras il va falloir se contenter de 47
même c'est pas sa partie
mais on va on va on a espoir que des
français viennent jouer quand même dans
la première table
on va peut-être tourné stéphane mais je
te rappelle comme ça il ya une petite
pub à mettre tous les deux meilleurs
qu'on comprenne bien un petit peu tout
le monde on va tout à l'heure mais ses
parfums donc on nous allons m'a demandé
aux mains imposé même je dirais même de
mètres dessiné toutes les fins en fait
il ya six minutes par heure ce qui est
beaucoup je trouve est bon pour partager
un petit peu le temps on a décidé de
faire trois minutes
en milieu de partie et 3000 en fin de
partie pour pâques est trop trop de
poses longues donc chaque demi heure on
se mettra trois minutes donc on va déjà
malheureusement déjà partir en pose
maintenant qu'on est calé que maintenant
qu'on est calé ouais donc je vous dis
une chose c'est pas nous qui décidons
partir en pause on n'est pas fatigué
tout va bien mais on a imposé par
tmz.com qui racontera avec twitch et on
doit faire des pauses toutes les demi
heures et c'est comme ça c'est pas nous
qui vit un profond et puis non on est on
est toujours là nous on est tranquille
on va discuter avec ses fans en fait
pendant ce temps là voilà voilà comment
ça va se passer
allez on vous dit je vous laisse du coup
je vous jure je vous laisse et les les
parties de 40 celles et puis je vous dis
à tout de suite
petites coupures attendez il faut que je
le
sais que vous allez voir la domination
de carl scène voilà
après la pub yes a tout de suite
a tout de suite
[Musique]
à
le
on
[Musique]
et nous sommes de retour donc tout s'est
passé en trois minutes mais on va dire
que c'est et oui recoucou comprendra
timing maintenant ses fans c'est ça
mieux en mieux sur la pub voilà c'est ça
donc car c'est vrai ya vachement basques
ont avancé un gros pressing et un gros
pressing dans cette partie comme à les
cases blanches pour équiper en soit
monté jusqu'à 4,5 donc à noter que les
blancs ont plusieurs plusieurs ruptures
une avec h4 une avec ses trois à quatre
qui doivent arriver pour ouvrir plus la
position est aussi f4 qui peut aussi
arriver plantes
notre très souple leroy nash carthage
chaque
l'europe si le renard passif l'aja tour
à cette coupe le voit ça peut arriver on
va attention à pas trop se faire
échanger les pièges c'est pas ça
démontre à cet hoax et 7
après ça reste solide pour les mains
pour ce t3 mais j'attends ce ça la
solide mais pas désagréables en fait en
pratique comment ces femmes c'est qu'au
quai pour leurs dealers dit la tient
avec baignoire mais humainement c'est
une position qu'on aimerait pas beaucoup
avoir particulièrement contre manuscrits
scène qui excellent dans ses positions
là et qui excelle dans toutes les
positions vous allez me dire mais
particulièrement dans ses positions là
les positions de travail
ça fait ça fait mal donc voilà avoir
déjà on voit il a envoyé le pion wépion
h il veut faire des brèches pour passer
ça va être intéressant aussi une clonage
qui est ouverte par ici un avoir aussi
et ça va revenir en jeu quatre bombes
belle position travail avec 4 voir
comment il va qu'on y va la jouer 3 et 4
a été saluée fait par grain de sel et
salut à tous
f4 f5 après sans doute à un moment
précis où il a eu un passage pour le
recasement
4,5 ça va attaquer le pion j'ai du coup
qui a forcé pion à l'est rien si je veux
sa bande plus prise on apprend le roi
rentrée sur g5 les infiltrés via h cinq
jeux 6 des idées comme ça peut être
sympa ça les routes est
très technique c'est pour ça qu'on aime
par et noir rose et xhaka on voit qu'à
voir les noirs c'est des fois une grosse
souffrance et c'est le jeu moderne comme
ça de jouer pour petit plus si le
chauffeur du monde sauf que là ils sont
parties rapides et du coup position très
désagréable à tenir avec peu de temps la
guerre les noirs on va voir on va voir
j'aime pas trop est ce qu'on n'irait pas
voir nos petits frenchies se fane
qu'elle restait peut-être sur grande
allée voir les frenchy alors je te sors
maxime qui a fait nul en 14 100 me l'a
dit a service saas un petit peu de
second et pourquoi on voit
l'écart esprits ce qu'avait des quatre
tours ben
est quoi un seul expert sait pas
grand-chose à temps parce que là je veux
que la partie
j'ai un petit bol
c'est mal à manger j'ai pas les jets
palais les caméras des autres joueurs
ou des deux des quatre qui est des cinq
je pense qu'ils analysent et un truc là
voilà un amant qui est d'apprendre en
prend à deux qui est répétition coup tu
sais pas si je peux réussir et à sortir
parce que j'ai pas la fin de la partie
en fait je me suis arrêté à tour bien
marqué nulle et après j'avais une bande
qui s'est mis tout seul en tout cas ça a
fait nul donc ça c'est décevant qu'un
beau maxime qui fait nuls en quinze
coups avec les blancs contre argent à 25
30 je sais pas pourquoi ça a fait nul
que malin
donc vous parler que on parlait de de
durabilité est un genre qui est très
dangereux dans ce cas dans cela embête
sa ville mais là y'a pas être parti en
fait donc c'est assez bizarre qu'il
fasse nul dans cette première partie en
tout cas je ne comprends pas on a une
répète
ouais ouais tu ne répète du coup firouz
les gars est ce que quelqu'un le voit
que ça parce que mois plus tard je le
cherche on nous a mis nakamura oui on
nous a parlé firoud déjà il joue et
apparemment contre 1 mètres roumains
quelqu'un a mis dans le chat tout à
l'heure
c'était tellement de joueurs peuvent
reprendre ça
alors contre costa qui
sait où st1 chu dans un monsieur à mites
monsieur deux amis qui nous avait donné
ce tuyau jeune homme rien voilà
oui poids pour aston au début c'était
légal sur pas mal d'échiquier puisque
c'est l'ouverture et maman rapide se
sont très bon théoricien et sont des
joueurs qui sont très bien les pièces
donc c'est normal qu'il n'y ait pas
encore de grosses différences qu'elles
se fassent et petit à petit bien sûr il
va y avoir des équipes qui vont
apparaître
travaux en est la partie qui en scène et
commencer le travail
d'accord c'était pas trop déséquilibrée
et on voit nakamura peut-être stéphane à
l'exemple peut-être que c'est une
occasion d'aller voir son style
caractéristique exactement nakamura au
métier
je les envoyais moi j'ai rien à faire
pour moi ça ne s'est pas trouvé les
joueurs plutôt que deux
et en fait ça c'est intéressant puisque
nakamura il joue et je vous donne
tchenko qu'on connaît bien le
championnat de france puisque il évolue
à apprendre oeuvre depuis quelques
années maintenant et c'est un excellent
théoriciens et on voit que pour
l'instant apparemment il a une sacrée
poubelle puisque il a un pion de moins
et puis la tacc paraît plus fait ce côté
côté noir
enfin voir surtout parce que c'est un
parti quand même parce que moi
j'aimerais bien en signe effectivement
se retrouver si mal si rapidement
en plus ça semble être un choix
intelligent ce qu'il a fait c'est à dire
depuis qu'ils l'anglais ce qu'ont à
cabourg a pour essayer de calmer un peu
le jeu wii lambert l'aiment et trois
dames si on envoie
j'aurais bien vu un plan avec des cats
souvent on voit des cadres rapide mais
en fait il l'a envoyé 2 des cas ouais
encore plus rapidement avec b3 foulée de
normand l'idée c'est de faire des cadres
dans la foulée pour moi je
vais 3 hommes et 3 femmes et 2 c'est
normal il a joué sans cavalier c3 pour
ça et là des cadres et l'idée c'est de
lancer des cartons et des cats alors que
4 1 c'est normal et après cavaliers un
cavalier ses deux sacs si ce genre de
l'histoire chéchia regarder ça on pourra
aussi jouer avec f3 bref puisque reiff 5
dans ce land position tout casser
3 way est autrement cavale et ses deux
ans joue sur les cases c'est intéressant
aussi ok vous devez connaître en tout
cas il a joué au cours des 4 mai c'est
un petit peu étonnant ce qui s'est passé
parce qu'il est très vite mal comme tu
le dit stéphane
des caps apparaît dans l'esprit mais
ces prix font f5 et prises des 4 mois
est ce que la
caution il est vrai il n'aurait pas pu
croquer la paire de fou parce que c'est
bizarre domaine le cavagnan h4 et pas
piqué souef 5 est-ce que ça réglait un
petit peu les problèmes pour lui qu'elle
va les prendre un par an
il avait du mal à récupérer
le pion décathlon moins dans les cases
blanches mais on a peut-être un pionnier
de moi quand même
mais c'est un petit peu étonnant qu'il
n'ait pas pris tu vois ses fans en
termes de compensations le fouet f5 avec
son cavalier h4 qui est au bord ça
paraît être le
la logique de
l'art de la position
la caméra qui est qui la caméra merci à
tous merci matou qui nous dit que
apparemment ça bastonne bien chesnais
peau et chez mamediarov mais sans balle
et vous allez voir c'est plutôt sympa en
tout cas dacca qui a une très très très
bonne position et si on n'a qu'à contre
porto rico donc de chacun c'est un
joueur très solide très solide voit pas
souvent perdu un peu
et l'ap lapan qu'est ce que c'est que
cette tante dieu là qu'on voit ces
fameux les tempes paraissent très
bizarre une 54 2 minutes ouais je ne
sois pas trop heureusement j'ai pas des
caméras barrios et je vais revenir sur
les caméras mais ça me semble pas
possible ça me semble pas possible
simplement
oui oui nac nac a
salué aux gays mais oui je pense que
c'est c'est franchement c'est
franchement pas facile la position pour
les blancs un peu décevant pour
dantchenko qui a un très bon théoricien
l'onglet la du sommet ayant quelque part
en rapide on obligé de jouer réflexe
alors peut-être qui s'est souvenu de
quelque chose et qu'au final bas il sait
il s'est trompé et et du cou et du coup
il s'est retrouvé très vite mal ce qui
est normal pour quelqu'un de son niveau
et c'est vrai que même là qu'à moi c'est
un joueur qui aime bien prendre les
pions
n'y a pas peur il n'a peur de rien vous
savez un très tactique
alors on va la voir peut-être un média
offre de là on a eu beau tiens ça se
sont terminées mais médoc mamediarov
l'explosion caméra d'or 18 rebelles
encore à la caméra car c'est de la
marche très bien
et on va bien sûr celle là mais j'ai
plusieurs caméras qui ne marche pas
qu'ils sont en noir
alors à riom et
donc les coûts marie garat fit jouer
contre 1 là encore un petit grand maître
polonais et du coup en fait ce qui se
passe au cycle c'est quand les tops jem
ont les blancs on fera 10 des petits
grands maîtres voilà
eh ben ça peut aller très très vite ça
peut aller très très vite et c'est
indienne classique pour l'instant avec
g3 fou g2 ou jusque-là par énormément de
choses et un pressing champion des six
voilà
stéphane la montre est donc être quatre
la pression est très dure déjà sait déjà
c'est déjà dur
vient pas facile ouverture en fait le
jeu avec des noirs qu'elle va laisser
5,5 atypique il en reste un den à la
casse et tout ça vous prend une
valorisation du jeu de pièces ou par
hyper intéressant alors généralement se
fout c'est de bons fous on va regarder
tout le temps et là on va les changer
pour pouvoir après jouer contre ce
mauvais fou et le gaver de maria en 4 et
cavaliers qui rentre au bercail qu'avait
db5 même classe ou en whaou cas et b5
relatifs tactique demain et garonne il
s'appuie si vous voulez il travaille
stratégiquement la position mais en
s'appuyant sur des tactiques c'est pour
ça que le joueur est hyper fort en fait
c'est pour ça que c'est un objet remis
ça à faire les deux en même temps et ça
c'est magique alors qu'on avait vus tous
les deux avec ses fans rapidement
cavaliers ou quatre qui semblait naturel
moyen cavally v5 c'est une petite
tactique de rien du tout mais ça vous
fait toujours gagner du temps car il est
sain que c'est plus précis
alors qu'avaient les baies cette cavale
et des 6es l'instar de cavaliers pieuvre
elle est beaucoup trop à la position
vous un bon fouilles après cette base la
conne ouvert j'ai aussi des 5e 6e tour
qui sont bien remises là c'est très dur
et là il a fini le spectacle avec chez
4g cadre là qui va qui va arriver et il
a mangé si vous mangez pas
il se prend un f5 je pense
oued à mach 4 aussi comme dans la partie
qui peut arriver arriva taquet plat et
stabiliser
et des rires non mais beaucoup de france
a
envoyé le tour des anciens en mai encore
fils enlevé sa tour et après il a fait
dans machete
c'est en clair on veut pas dire autre
chose voilà ainsi la fin si les dégage
une impression de puissance eux comme
avec les blancs toujours pareil avec les
blancs c'est quand même plus facile pour
ces joueurs là
alors et je ne trouve toujours pas s'ils
ont besoin a lancé l'idée en bas là dans
le
sait pas trop où
ils accueillent la camry l'aï landru
long de six roads a pas tant que ça
c'est un guide et 26,50 j'avais vu 26
novembre je vais le trouver ouais chez
moi je reviens dès la liste lo c'est moi
il est absent 6
sauver 10 en un an ils ont ils ont ils
ont mélangé en fait les femmes et les
hommes la nouvelle zac journal c'est dur
désolé les caméras plantes de la fidh et
l'envoi d'un cas moi sur la vidéo
donc firo déjà contraint m romain à
24,40 donc ultra favori mais bon pas
grand chose de fait pour l'instant
c'était quoi
une espagnole ah oui une espagnole
steijns néos tanit
et les calais là les pendules aussi ne
paraissent pas bonne malheureusement
pour nous ces femmes mais
malheureusement je peux pas je peux pas
te bases ou mais sûrement mais c'est un
autre fait à ce point je ne sais pas
mais ça qu on l'a un peu
et là je pensais des bugs
une bonne remarque en disant que si
rogers a été un peu maigrichon à 26,56
on aimerait bien le maigrichon comme
perugia mais je suis assez d'accord avec
la remarque de romain pour autant mais
c'est vrai que c'était assez marrant le
tourneur ci est passé de 1800 ego en
classique qui donnent partant avec
enfants afin certainement rapide par
rapport à moi et je pense qu'il est
peut-être même plus fort encore au rapid
a peut-être que en fait c'est un joueur
qui peut gagner tu peux du monde alors
que généralement un joueur à 26,50 n'est
pas du tout capable de gagner vos
besoins maintenant on va bien par contre
il n'ya pas une si bonne position à
notre ami phil rogers et troisième
parties conviendront m le roumain a
ouais c'est ça pareil faut que
l'alternance est simple mais
certainement qu'ils avancent avantage
noir dans cette position mais après il
est malin puis encore le roi les
cavaliers et on sait très bien qu'ils
pourraient faire des cochonneries
peut-être interne ouais ouais les
cavaliers comme des trous ainsi c'est
toi mais c'est loin d'être fait cette
histoire est clairement mais ça viendra
par de fou
mais toujours moins de gens ambitieux
c'est bien c'est bien tu l'as pas faire
ça mais attention si le meilleur moyen
1,2 ha ouais c'est le meilleur moyen de
contrer je le connais pas tu le connais
tu vas me le mou je connais c'est un
jeune d'avoir quoi tu vas voir c'est
hélas 24,50 je crois qu'en fidh il a
plus que ça il à 2005 comme ça donc
c'est un genre qui veulent mettre de
grands maîtres en tout cas mais ok
contre infi rose normalement ça va pas
casser
ouais mais c'est des joueurs comme tu
dis les jeunes qui adore ce genre de
cadence les rats et milite sélection
sont très instinctif en fait ils lâchent
leurs coûts et ça peut faire mal
j'aimerais bien avoir les points faibles
c'est pas de chance c'est l'histoire
elle est un lieu sympa elles sont pas 21
ans pour boom un mail à web 21 ans du
coup c'est moins bien mais c'est pas ça
24,50 21 ans bon c'est normal
à 4,15 ça serait vraiment plus jamais de
passer un peu ça
ok donc on va voir qui est le plus
facile hein je trouve ici s'il arrive à
jouer cavalier ou quatre cavaliers c'est
peut être pas mal d'attention aussi aux
pions qui part en selle sur f2 aussi des
fois
ok est ce qu'on retournerait pas voir
nakamura peut-être je sais pas j'ai
phanou yes
lorna cas où est il parce qu'il avait
vraiment lui pour le coup vous le savez
à un très bon avantage est ce qu'il a
réussi à convertir contre donne tchenko
a promis ravoir aussi un peu car arsène
voir ce qui se passe ouais c'est une
partie très technique la suite de la
partie de cartes scène donc il voulait
oui ça a vraiment vraiment bien bien est
mauvais on s'arrêtait à sait plus trop
où là il s'est passé beaucoup de choses
comment ils arrivent voyant rapide ça
évolue hyper vite forcément la cavale de
cinq essais 5 permettent à changer des
pièces
autour des 3 lorsque vous tombez sur tv7
gagner un round 2 en à la tour de sa
cavale et 3 et 4
ok dame ces cadres hier pour des choses
qui vont avoir lieu
on a vu que t'as pas réussi à faire la
différence et du coulin vous voyez à la
paire de fou dans la finale et pour le
coup c'est al'avantage des blancs
nakamura et qui était vraiment bien tout
à l'heure il est en grande difficulté et
eu un très fort coup de dôme tchenko
d'ouvrir sur les cases noires le foot
cases noires qu'il est le seul à
posséder hélas avec une position de
pressing nakamura masse faire presser
donc là on voit que les gens commencent
à jouer avec un je pense que niveau du
timing nouveau des pendules on n'était
pas bons la tête - parce qu'on voit que
nos chiens régime stresse beaucoup en
fait dans cette partie et s'ajoute à
amasser des
dons jean gaudet qui joue un coup la
viande la pendule
je pense qu'il a moins de dix secondes à
la pendule 1 je pense que je pense que
le temps il est ok à peu près
ouais c'est possible c'est possible a
pas vu le pas vu le temps passer est ce
que tu voudrais voir quarantaine de
minutes - puisqu'ils se cacher car vous
aurez vite fait de me plaît embrassez
les deux parties vont car c'est hyper
intéressant qui presse tranquillement
bamba ya de fortes chances de nuls non
une fin un peu n'importe quoi sur les
caméras désole me change tout
les gaffes chance deux nuls maintenant
pour carlson puisqu'il ya eu vraiment de
beaucoup de liquidation quand vous le
voyez
là déjà en enlevant un pion b4 même en
sacrifiant cavaliers y aurait de très
fortes chances de nul
c'est une position du parti qui risque
de faire de faire mieux l'homme quand
même
le cavalier est un petit peu bizarre
mais
qui promet un le cavalier qu'il faut
régler
voyez il est quasiment fermé mais est-ce
que c'est suffisant
semble-t-il que non mais en tout cas on
avait dit que c'était pas de grands
maîtres de la même classe et on avait
dit aussi que sur une partie tout était
encore possible
on voit que
le joueur géorgien fait une très grosse
partie avec baignoire
batterie
ce qui vient en plus c'est que le joueur
géorgien il a gardé une réserve de temps
tout fait ça nous permet de d'imaginer
qu'il peut encore résister sans problème
clairement on classe les noirs je pense
qu'ils pourront rester césario mettre en
cavale sur une case peut-être plus
solides comme ses cadres oui ou venir
croquer bekaert vous bien les
argelésiens après avoir un pratique tour
fou contre tours
une fois que l'effet soit changé c'est
pas si facile à tenir
c'est vrai mais j'imagine qu'à ce niveau
là on est un grand maître normalement
ils pourraient bon jeu mais contre un
joueur polonais c'est il me l'avait
tenue hyper facile avec peu de temps la
pendule qui est à blanc la défense
d'édouard parce que voilà tu as la
pression sur tout le monde fou comme 400
ou sata de noyer toute la famille
il ya une partie célèbre aux olympiades
comme ça c'est
c'est le regretté grand max les touches
keane qui est joué contre la russie je
vais jouer à 27,50 il avait tenu pendant
quarante six coups et puis il a filé
sattouf on a alors que l'idée pas du
tout obligé quoi donc c'est vrai que
c'est toujours une position il ya un peu
de pression quand même on a vu des
grands maîtres perdre cette finale tour
fou contre tours qui normalement doit
faire nul sur un bon jeu sur un bon jeu
du défenseur
sauf cas particuliers bien sûr elle le
roi la bande des nouvelles positions
mais normalement las c'est quand même
pas pas facile mais quand elle va
presser un tout du long c'est il va pas
lâcher ça prend il va essayer leur pc ça
commence bien j'ai envie de dire pour
des sites web et 5 c'est possible de
façon le cabinet parle pas beaucoup de
cases un échec surmonter ces deux
des deux voiliers du travail être le roi
en play off the map ok c'est peut-être
réguler il romain légal yannick jeu
léché fier au nul chez fil rouge de ben
c'est pas si étonnant que ça n'était pas
bien il n'y a pas de bus nous
positionnons je sais des rorquals par
witsel
magnésium pour te répondre à cinq points
on n'a peut-être pas précisé aujourd'hui
si on a dit ça gronde demain 4 à partir
de 15h encore et après demain 4 aussi
donc c'est 5 4 4 à partir de 15 heures
chaque jour donc aujourd'hui ça va nous
amener à 20h30 ça va s'unir 21h
peut-être
et après les autres jours ça se
terminera vers aller 19h30 quelque chose
comme ça 20h pacs c'est ça donc donc nul
signe un donc appel à pétition il ya eu
des cas vous aurez
sans doute un peu de masse qui bien
payés parce qu'il peut tenter un bon
après c'est facile à dire tout fait ce
qu'on aurait gagné avec des noirs mais
c'était encore trop de choses
ouais c'est ça on aurait fait un
pressing un pressing à la française
c'est à dire bras tu joues mais tu
gagnes pas quoi
3 3 par exemple
échec 3-3 et justement ça c'est vrai
qu'il bouge pas en fait chez rhodia il
était quasiment coin c'est ce qu'on
appelle tous besoin que vous connaissez
sans doute le terme c'est vraiment je ne
peux pas bouger j'ai aucun cool avec les
blancs là il en a quelques-uns mais sont
pas forcément très fort tour à 3 se
répartit des jolis coups
les moules au rayon des deux les faux
faux faux faux vraiment travailler la
pose encore mais
il ya toujours le problème de f cfa sur
vire 3g un
moyen et il ya toujours pire c'est près
de 900 qui est le problème et je pense
que à cause de ça et à cause du temps il
n'a pas su trouver les clés mais il
était un petit peu embêté pour pour
consigner quoi après ok mieux confier
aux usa c'est quand même pas mal hein tu
es complètement bien jeune et demi à 24
40 bon je vais pas refuser à lui comme
56 rosa bon moi je suis moche suis
tanné aussi un amateur si on met des
ménages a bien joué les partisans de
noms mais je pense que j'aime bien
j'aime bien jouer mais après oui là
c'est un accent conseils que tu donnes
pour tous ceux qui nous regardent faut
jouer des parties 1 de toute façon faut
les jouer au maximum c'est comme ça que
vous allez avoir énormément d'expérience
sens on peut le dire et après dans
certaines circonstances de qualif et
autres là on peut accepter des nuls un
peu plus complaisante mais sinon faut
tenter faut jouer c'est
pourquoi ça on va comprendre
qu'il éléphants grand maître ses manies
gagne des positions à 0 0 la carlsson si
vous voyez l'ordinateur c'est une
position à 0 0 et il est en train
d'essayer de travailler pour pour que
l'adversaire se prennent les pieds dans
le tapis parce que c'est pas si simple
supposition la force cavaliers qui s
cavaliers qui est hors jeu et l'eau et
en fin de compte le roi qui peut
toujours se faire un petit peu attaquées
avec la tour fou mais bon pour l'instant
à trouver des remplaçants b 3-1 qui
empêche le foot venir
à moins que wayne en foule à tour l'
échec voilà c'est à retenir
mais
[Musique]
mai n'a rouiba la position est égal mais
il ya toujours pas mal de choses peuvent
arriver genre lecavalier dans le mail a
pas de cadeau camaïeu il fallait lui
parle bayer n'est pas attaqué mais la
pièce est donc du coup bien trop
récemment position faire des choses
pendant qu'au liban pas bougé
on va démonter droit et c'est un des
choses c'est un nom je pense qu'arsène
malgré tout à quelques chances de guerre
de positions
grâce à la pression en fête qui met dans
cette position non c'est pas facile
[Musique]
en a qu'un ça a pas mal évolué on n'a
qu'à lui à tour michel
oui là il ya une grosse finale pour
aller voler peut-être plusieurs fois
cette finale
beaucoup
ça y est on voyait tout à l'heure
c'était donne tchenko qui mettait la
pression à nakamura avec la paire de
fouet puis la paire de fou n'est plus là
et malheureusement il est en train de
voir ses espoirs complètement anéanti là
il va bien mais là il va perdre besoin
depuis le plus de pions cinq années de
perdues sur voie il ya des deux
candidats et je prends ici est sûre
revoilà la loire échec si tu viens ici
je prends pions et si tu viens l'accès
aux échecs turmel rangée 5 d'avoir tous
rêvent cinq échecs et or quand la vente
évidemment tu peux peut-être aussi
manger 6 mai après les changes là j'ai
aussi quelqu'un qui avance d'ailleurs
même si on reconnaît ici c'est peut-être
ça la problématique salue l'appui en
bessin garé deux tubes et règne sur le
monde fr que tu me fasses jean roch
effectivement indien et si tu manges ici
en cinq ans peut-être nous faire tout
reprend ici cinq échecs pour changer les
tours et après on comble où dame nature
c'est même le plus simple on peut être y
aura du nouveau mais c'est pas le top du
top
les caméras qui sont ces mêmes makala
toujours pas réglé un les caméras
duda gagner c'est moi et ça
m'intéressait directement je crois alors
duda a gagné je les paye tous
regardaient
nom n'a pas du tout été le voir non et
ouais mais là ce n'est même plus
question de deux secondes c'est surtout
que ces impositions est foutu il va pas
rater ça
c'est son fond de commerce de gagner ce
genre de position
tranquille c'est vraiment tranquille
alors
voilà ça fait
on va pas la suite de la partie en plus
entre entre duda et cas bousillant ouais
ça y renvoie pas très grave pas été gâté
samedi un petit peu de temps
yes alors toi tu étais pour ponton pour
un petit nez
exactement d'ailleurs exactement il faut
qu'on parle aussi des termes du paris 1
exactement je les sais tu vois définir
les termes du paris fc a plus
d'expérience sur ce jeu là que moi la
dernière fois ce
la dernière fois tu j'avais déterminer
les termes du paris et puis en plus tu
avais été dur avec toi parce que tu
avaient parié dans une situation
délicate pour ton poulain alors qu'ils
étaient déjà amené
du coup du coup je sais que
tu es généralement précisé paul a mis
une pression de dingue autant quoi c'est
fou quoi mais dépôt il joue très très
vite façon
5h gagné donc déjà on n'est pas trop mal
dans nos pronos voilà on a choisi
les derniers de la classe on est beau
et on voit aussi que nos deux français
donc maxime et effet rose là on fait nul
aujourd'hui donc on va réfléchir sur
carlina voir un peu comment ça comment
la partie se termine et je pense qu'on
va essayer de retrouver les caméras mais
j'ai des problèmes de caméra là je
n'arrive pas
à les voir je ne sais pas de grimm
pourquoi
michel qui nous fait un petit coucou
en remercie ils sont abonnés à la chaîne
chaise comme iniesta c'est au top merci
beaucoup michel
c'est au top alors sein
[Musique]
du coup là on va finir qu'est ce qui
nous reste nous reste à part karlsson
est normalement se départit tous les
heures 15 donc en fait normal de
reprendre dix minutes la prochaine ronde
d'accord un ces femmes là alors j'avais
le
mois
ggg normalement tout ce qu'il faut pour
déterminer cela ap ouais prochaine ronde
16h15 c'est fou c'est hors 15 17h30 il
est 16h 6 et on voit que magnus est en
train de travailler c'est toujours égal
mais voilà le cavaliere sortie essaye
peut se faire technique et pendant
prendra un moment
en même temps dès que j'arrive sur noir
c'est pas si facile donc il n'a pas
avoir envie de mettre le pion son noir
sinon ça autorise qu'un rallye c'est
cissé chaque et après ça devient plus
facile peut-être pour le défenseur
donc magnus est encore en train de de
faire le show
pas évident pas évident de de passer
alors qu'est ce que veut dire son
dernier coup il lui dit ben vas-y prend
option je prends donc un voilier anjou
torfou contours pendant des heures ça
commence bien pour cette première partie
de magnus carlsen et son adversaire n'a
pas envie d'aller dans tour fou contours
du coup c'est ça va être très très chaud
là c'est c'est pas facile pas facile du
tout alors là c'est le money time
on voit il ya la minute pour chaque
joueur
là mais c'est pas facile a maintenue
s'il doit pas trop savoir comment passer
alors qu'avant que cette finale la tombe
et 5 et font cavalier est censé être nul
mais il faut savoir bien sûr la défendre
ben ça se passe d'ailleurs et c'est
parti on a pour la première ronde déjà
roi tour fou contre aux atours donc on
va réviser nos défenses avec stéphane
avec la position cochrane et la défense
en septième rangée j'ai hâte que
stéphane nous montre tout ça
le cadeau empoisonné
et je suis contournement en plus c'est
pas vu c'est bien dans ces cas là bien
évidemment évidemment il ya une des
leaders avec un pacte avec un taux avec
un tour devant l'ot à ça on va avoir un
peu comme comment il voit la cave en
septième mais c'est ce qui va choisir je
pense le joueur c'est ce qui en pratique
ouais c'est bien
on va voir mais
c'est une défense un peu paradoxal
d'ailleurs parce qu'on se laisse
finalement guidé sur la sur la première
rangée sur un des bords de l'échiquier
si vous voulez et notre tour va être en
deuxième rangée eux et ça va nourrir des
thèmes de pâtes voilà on va voir ça
j'espère qu'on va assister à une belle
défense à
ça quand même bête qu'ils arrivent et
disent ici et faire perdre la position
de nul c'est quand même dommage
pour le joueur je reviens ici avec les
doigts donc là il ya la règle des 50
coup ça qu'on a réglé 50 coup il est
apparu aux 84 fin 84e coup un c'est
évident un écrou de brun donc en fait on
a cinquante coups à partie le 84e pour
gagner la partie
voilà donc là il tourne l'idée c'est
quand même d'amener le roi sur
[Musique]
sur un des bords de l'échiquier pour le
maté
mais c'est pas si facile que ça
évidemment donc en train de travailler
des fois c'est ont fait des petits coups
juste pour provoquer la faute adverse
je vois très bien le joueur le joueur
défendre voilà c'est typique de la
position de
de cochrane a finalement avec la tour
qui vient clouer le fou on peut me
restait sur la première rangée
et faire des coups comme
3,5 c'est pas c'est pas gênant puisque
le roi ne peut pas avancer à cause du
courage
donc il défend bien pour l'instant le
joueur géorgien et le jour géorgie à ne
pas être trop inquiet
dans cette position là à tel point que
magnus pour éviter les clous âgées il va
ce n'est même pas en opposition il
cherche à changer un peu la position
voilà faut faire attention ici ouais
il a mis son talent on s'en fout en
barrages généralement ainsi leur grosse
tennis voilà déjà pour essayer de deux
temps levé sur un contrôle tour ici pour
venir couper un peu le roi
donc c'est pas facile à défendre cette
position là on regarde scène vraiment
joue
un travail voilà il s'est peu au pire
des cas serait cabaye fait nul
et et c'est plus facile à défendre ici
en pratique c'est pas si facile hein
il arrive normal il foule à un web ce
qu'il arrive face il va sans matelas
toujours peur de sa main des chèques
dont croit ici forcé
un ace sur sa ferveur échec et au retour
1 dont 3,5 obligé mais ce sur voila je
vais pas tourner là il retourne là bas
tout quoi
c'est une blague ou quoi aïe aïe aïe non
mais c'est une blague
[Rires]
la compo craquer
regardez bien regardez bien ma caméra là
ce qui va se passer aïe aïe aïe
incroyable ce qui s'est passé dans cette
partie avec le roi telle loi les y
oblige et sniper de la tour
eiffel à 3,3 à droite ça c'est vraiment
une gaffe mayroy saint camille revient
on voit cinq j'ai pas trouvé non parce
que ce retour là pour mater ici deux
tours là
non
alors est ce qu'on trouvait jouer roi à
5 ou pas
c'est incroyable il a réussi à le
travailler j'espère qu'il a regardé la
finale pourra travailler alors que et
poser des problèmes pratiques un
peut-être alors que le joueur géorgien
penser que sur que sur oise bassens à la
place ils pensaient qu'ils s'y perdre et
parce que je m'adapte et sur sa jeunesse
et sa c4 yaya toure c4 et d'un seul coup
et ouais bah c'est ce que la taille
comme ses cadres oui ces trouvailles
mais bon on sait plus trop de temps à
l'abandon du nom mais il a bien tourné à
moi j'ai eu en partie lance je peux me
dire que j'avais pas tourné comme un
vieux singe avait pas réussi à poser des
problèmes à fides quelle belle
démonstration ouais c'est clair salut à
toi au lit tôt autour des 4 3 3 sur
tours c'est 400 pages que j'ai ou par
mail à tous mettons à l'asim grosse
gaffe quand même eu trois grosses gaffes
alors véritable big ben a peut-être
qu'il avait vu que dans l'autre camp qui
perdait aussi c'est une tête qu'il a
essayé celle là
même il a plus de chances d'un roi à
cinq quand même
les ronces il est sorti en plus et pas
plus
c'est dommage en tout cas alors il face
à personne en fait si tu veux il avait
quand même bien défendus au départ le
grand maître vous verra julie mais c'est
pour ça qu'on dit que la défense en
deuxième rangée plus facile à tenir à
l'est un peu plus stéréotypé ce que
c'est
oui c'est ça donc donc quand vous aimez
manger donc pas vous montrer un
basculeur là on n'a pas eu n'a pas n'a
pas pu voir l'exemple mais il ya en gros
il ya une défense mais là je ne peux pas
peut-être que je peux c'est de la montre
et la défense sont descendus des
justes pour pour voir un peu comment ça
se passe en gros l'idée c'est d'arriver
à ce type de pollution avec tours échec
en pour que le roi sont en gros pour
virer de rock hill sur foot rendra le
répète ça c'est une race assez
classique
voilà ça c'est un destin méconnu
est en fait de leroy elle a tout pour
son corps ils sont assez proches
normalement aussi touré roi noir pour
pour faire corps sur première et
deuxième rangée wave 3 hier dans le
démarrage de championnat normand ça
reprend dans une minute stéphane lardy
fo y font escale à moissac pour
rapidement la guerre parce que on a
oublié vers la petite pause yes je ne
vais pas le seul malheureusement mais
c'est super bien ça tombe bien là c'est
fini et donc on va reprendre là de la
deuxième ronde dans quelques minutes les
marchands ce qui laisse un petit délai
aux joueurs tête de cinq minutes à
quelque chose comme ça mais en tout cas
on se retrouve en trois minutes guess a
tout de suite
ça commençait fort a tout de suite avoue
[Musique]
m
il
et
[Musique]
il
oh
[Musique]
à
non
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
salut à tous or on va pouvoir faire
notre petit point sur les paris aussi
tes fans
ouais
hallucinant
bref stéphane contentant plus
apparemment thème yutz et chantons bien
mais mais mais ça on a plutôt en sont
voilà plus de son moi je tenterais bien
ça va nous mener
pourtant il me regarda si vous saviez à
quel point ce qu'a dit stéphane était
pertinent chez chez hyper triste hyper
triste pour vous
parce que là stéphane vous fait un petit
bilan petit bilan et vous rappelez
aïe aïe aïe
voilà les gens ils vont ils ont ils vont
revenir les boîtes il faut être hyper
content de tendre à nouveau j'espère en
tout cas j'espère j'espère toujours pas
de sont apparemment pour toi ces femmes
quant au micro et récalcitrants
j'espère que je sais pas si les gens
menton de moi de mon côté
c'est a perdu tous les sons ou seulement
je sais pas ouais ouais
des fois la technique et dure deux fois
la technique est dur fatou modo mais oui
michel mais non et là c'est pas clair
c'est pas clair c'est pas clair même
rêve
stéphane seulement alors stéphane
seulement 7 à des fins on entend que
kevin voilà ok bah écoutez on pendant
que stéphane règles cela
donc on peut vous dire pour vous faire
un petit point
mv la finul firoud déjà a fait nul je
vous rappelle qu'un petit paris
d'ailleurs entre nous avec stéphane
stéphane et pour fil rouge a entre
guillemets il pense que phil rogers va
va finir devant un verre et moi j'ai
parié sur mv tout simplement donc on est
à égalité ils ont admis tous les deux et
on a décidé de parier sur des outsiders
stéphane a choisi duda moi j'ai choisi
nepomniachi je pense qu'il va se refaire
ils ont gagné tous les deux et d'autre
part on a dit qu'il y avait eu un petit
événement quand même pour cette première
partie avec la partie de magnus carlsen
qui a duré et je vais le grand maître
gouvernance julie qui est un grand
maître à un niveau plus confidentielle
autour de deux mille cinq cents lots
et google à julia fait une super partie
aurait dû tenir là nul contre majorque
en scène qui a fait tourner la position
théorique roi du refoud qu'on droit tour
et qui a réussi à le battre tout
simplement
que voilà attention tout le monde tout
le monde se donne des petits conseils
stéphane adam foote et muse et c'est ça
je sais que j'ai du mal quand la route
de stéphane apparemment c'est pas moi
c'est fou tout le monde te dit parfait
et moi je ne t'entends plus c'est la
dure réalité
alors que ce facilement incroyable moi
je tente en plus du tout
une technique récalcitrante
et à ce que blanc tu m'as une tente est
raide on vous entend tous les deux télés
nous ne s'entend plus moi je tente en
plus je peux dire j'ai plus de retours
sont stéphane tout le monde est content
à part moi ses fans je n'ai plus accès à
tadu se voit
alors que ça va bientôt recommencer mais
on s'amuse comme on peut hein pendant
pendant l'équipe pose avec stefano joue
avec les sons de chacun
bah malfato modo je pense que c'était
pas n'a rien dit
on a les parties les gars alors pourquoi
je n'entends plus à moi je n'ai vraiment
rien fait je vais vérifier que celle du
son telle une voiture pas
ici de
on passe
à m'amuser alors qu'est ce qui se passe
c'est où
alors alors c'est dur de ne pas
s'entendre moi je tente en plus un
stéphane sélestat sur
quelle quelle tristesse
ça je l'avais pas prévu ce scénario
incroyable voilà c'est ça merci romain
tu as bien résumé la situation
j'entendais stéphane assaillent et
stéphane tu es de retour avec moi je
t'entends qui m'attend ouais ouais ouais
ça y était de retour pour moi mais est
ce que le tchad sont en bas normalement
oui enfin cinq femmes
est ce que est ce que tous filé le
retour à voilà c'est magnifique ah oui
c'est un sketch au fait des petits
sketchs en fait on s'est entraîné avec
ses fans ont fait des petits sketchs
technique on les a bossé c'est pas
facile c'est parque de l'impro on va pas
vous mentir
faire des sketchs comme ça de haut
niveau un comique c'est
franchement pas mal pour le coup ouais
parce que je vois à peu près ce que tu
vis c'est pas sympa
hockey et du coup on va faire un petit
point il ya des bons matches là
franchement
magnus carlsen pas jouer personne
terssac haillan
l'arménien à presque deux mille six
cents lots nippon ce sera aussi un
joueur polonais à 2600 quasiment lots
marzocco
donc voilà c'est des 25-50 26 maintenant
qu'ils sont posées aux différentes stars
quelles sont ses stars on a cité maladie
rend tout à l'heure du beauf qui a déjà
été vice champion du monde en rapide
green shoots qui avait été cité artemiev
on n'en a pas parlé jusque là mais c'est
un super joueur aussi mauvaise escient
galles bref toute la troupe est là il ya
vraiment il ya vraiment du lourd vous le
savez et du coup ça va ça va bientôt
repartir là sur les calmes on voit
qu'ils sont tous prêts à jouer
normalement ça devait redémarrer à à
16h15 oui le miel on suit mpl ensuite
tous les joueurs français alors je suis
moniteur
100g une question parce que là en fait
on voit bien que ça envoie votre maxime
vachier lagrave qui apparaît table vite
devant rapport d'un médiateur qui a
gagné la partie alors est ce que il y
avait un prêt de retransmission sur sa
partie mais quand même ils organisent
savoir aussi d'homme parce qu'en fait il
ya deux artisans nul assez rapidement et
on sait vraiment ce qui se passait donc
il est possible qu'en fait la partie de
maxime tout à l'heure il ya eu un bug
avec avec pièces comme et qu'on a tapé
sur sa partie mais j'ai peut-être que du
coup
oui marie la gagnante vous pourrez faire
bosser le chat sur ce sujet là est ce
que vous allez un chat à les rechercher
pour la
responsable responsable des résultats
tous ceux qui ont mis
prenez que sébastien résultat vous êtes
responsable des résultats vous allez
voir maxime boire est normal
c'est une bonne nouvelle bonne nouvelle
que maxime huot est la leur et réussi a
réussi à gagner et là ma caméra qui
mène vers la finul apparemment un
magnésium et nous
nous confirme ça
pendant que pékin kharkov nous chante
une chanson dans le chat
ok il a fait nul et le reste est reparti
a fait nul à magnus c'est quoi
exactement ok baky et d'un serveur qui
soit
peut-être que les goûts de chasse comme
les places par lots quand même
- ben stansall hermes dubaï pourquoi pas
bah ouais mais bon moi je mettrais
pouvoir classement les romains qui
nourrit table le 8 g du beurre friedman
enfin moi je table de 8 sur qu'est-ce
qu'on en fait un jeu n'est pas le rush
des soieries
616 armée ouais
donc
donc ok donc l'heure du coup alors oui
donc je pense que l'heure est venue de
parler de l'eau paris au défi de [ __ ]
tout à l'heure j'ai brodé un peu un
moment quand tu étais dans la technique
j'en ai reparlé un peu de tout on en
était mais peu importe ça n'empêche pas
de rappeler par ips y en a qui sont pas
au courant ouais et ça ça paraît
important alors du coup dans la ghana
qui sait que de sauter ça me saoule en
vue
alors du coup entendre parler on avait
on avait chacun un poulain donc tout da
pour ma part et toi c'était nepomniachi
donc oui sachant qu'on n'a pas le droit
car c'est lena ka ou bien de préciser
parce que l'art en selle par loana cas
et pas le droit aux français ben
exactement une fois les quatre passes
est mon favori était duda et favori de
kevin était était né peau
du cou
on a un petit pari en jeu donc on ne
sait pas encore quoi parier oui sachant
qu'on a on voulait aussi parier sur
maxime et firouz savoir lequel des deux
va tenir devant l'autre
donc à ce qu'on fait un combo est ce qu
on fait
comment on fait
ajustement moi je te laisse et j'ai
laissé libre cours à son imagination et
evans copieux tu m'as dit que tu étais
un parieur invétéré du coup je me suis
dit allez choisir quelque chose de 2
juste de deux réglo je te fais
entièrement confiance et j'ai surtout
confiance en mes poulains tu ne connais
ça j'ai fait déchanter à un moment un
mais c'est vrai que
alors est ce que dans le chat vous allez
avoir des idées de paris qu'on pourrait
mettre en place ou dans la lah
frigoriste la prise de ri sionnel de
laquelle on pourrait on pourrait faire
tout ça parce qu'on pourrait se faire
chacun d'eux paris indépendant et puis à
la fin on parle chacun peut qu'on verra
ce qui se passe ou alors
pourquoi pas droit français par entre
nous en fait on voulait parler des
joueurs qui n'étaient pas français ni
on avait déjà fait des paris de deux
français et on a estimé salut à toi
templiers on a estimé quelque chose on a
estimé que naka carlsen est pire ouldja
faisait partie des gros gros favoris on
a associé du coup mvele à cela et
et
dans ces conditions on a choisi les
autres prétendants parmi les autres
prétendants et on a fait aussi un petit
pari sur des français
mais caruana et on a pu faire aussi par
métal ça fait partie il faisait partie
des favoris or des français de naka car
c'est très clairement mais ses fans a
choisi a choisi duda très bon choix et
je pense que l'epo c'est la grosse cote
quand même donc j'espère que ça a bien
tourné pour lui se refaire en blitz
après et rapide après la désillusion on
joue pas du monde en lan voilà
à carmona je pense qu'il peut il peut
gagner le mans rapide d'un magasin
barrios le nombre de points d'avance que
maclean's or à la fin du tournoi sur le
deuxième
tout est possible ou accra ghana qui
c'est la surenchère alors déjà est ce
que est ce qu'on pense aux cartes 1,3
s'est passé
ok il est bien d'abord il est mais c'est
quand même chaud les thèmes du monde
derrière ya du monde c'est un tournoi on
peut être en forme et
ok à la partie ont commencé on en voit
on va et c'est parti et on nous demande
pourquoi karpov n'est pas là bas car
profil fait plus il est il est
maintenant retraité fait plus d
exhibition qu'autre chose mais
techniquement vu que c'est ouvert à
n'importe qui qui a plus de deux mille
cinq cent cinquante lots il pourrait le
faire
mais il est plaisant de compétition
je vois sur les caméras que les gens ont
commencé à jouer chez moi ça n'a pas
commencé à jouer ouais tout à l'air bien
quand il ya eu un incident et les oc et
n'ont toujours pas les caméras
d'ailleurs j'ai un problème de caméra
les gars franchement
mais y'aura pas que sans faute pour
quinzaine à jemelle annonce aussi c'est
pas possible c'est pas possible c'est
trop trop dur on a vu que déjà elle est
l'humain a gagné sa première partie
contre un joueur bien plus modeste que
lui
il a gagné parti c'est pas facile comme
partie 1 qu'il a eu la fine par ailleurs
été c'était c'était intéressant de voir
que il a continué pendant des lustres
une position à 0 0 il a fini par faire
craquer l'adversaire c'est ça c'est ça
le truc il faut il faut jouer il faut
jouer longtemps la qualité des gros
joueurs c'est de ne pas perdre la foi
dans leur position des hyper positif est
justement de réussir à faire craquer
l'adversaire même quand ces gars il ya
que comme ça qu'ils sont aux joueurs de
type erp haut niveau c'est à dire qui et
voilà ils sont plutôt dans le
dépassement sous tend à à croire dans
leur position est allée jusqu'au bout
alors que c'est facile de
psychologiquement se démotiver en partie
à ses fans ont marre et la partie de
cartes scène et
tout le monde s'est donné le mot avec
ses petites petit espagnol à base de 2 à
4 détroit les anti anti marshall est
plutôt dans le style de d'espagnol
positionnelle
c'est pas
je pensais voir cavaliers arrivé en c3
fidesz pas qu'on peut aussi mettre en d2
bon c'est un remake des partis qu'on a
vu d'ailleurs pendant le pendant le
monde avec avec carlson et enée peau un
sens et pas très rigolo est ce qu'on
peut est-ce qu'on peut aller s'amuser
avec d'autres positions
donc là c'est un peu le même genre de
but
daouda
un petit bouddha allons voir son poulain
un peu pour voir ce qui donne allez donc
de da qui a les noirs ici
je pensais qu'on avait plus s'amuser que
s'arracheront secteur ils vendent du
rêve et
ouais non la ce c'est pas drôle vous
êtes d'accord je pense je pense qu'on
risque d'aller d'aller changer un petit
peu de deux parties à temps est là
un petit nakamura ça fait longtemps aux
besoins de forest et 23 c'est un joueur
qui aime beaucoup jouer active jouer
même en blé de soi c'est un joueur assez
gambler oui et puis là on est dans une
grande variantes de de l'année museau
assez connu un épisode âme celle de
dessins qu'elle est apparue assez
tardivement dans les années 2000 2010 on
va dire
et maintenant les skis et jouer le plus
alors quand on vend jeu plutôt b6 dans
cette position-là donc là l'idée en fait
des noirs qui ont perdu rapidement leur
père de fou et le centre c'est d'être
développé beaucoup plus rapidement que
l'adversaire
est ce qui se passe tout simplement et
on devrait voir le coup c'est ça qui
arrivait très très vite et noir
c'est tout rond ces huit très vite voilà
jouer sur la vence de développement
généralement enfin beaucoup de fois dont
on voit on le voit dans les musées les
noirs ont l'avancé développement avec un
torrent s'est vite
donc ok c'est une pression je pense
qu'il peut être qui peut être sympa à
suivre pour la suite parce que c'est
assez dynamique pour les mâles c'est
plus rigolo
alors qu'arras n'a pas encore vu car
voilà qui joue contre un met raffiné
avec grec kke à 25,60
donc ce genre grecques j'ai déjà vu
beaucoup de compétition soit rapide
oublie que même sur internet et c'est un
excellent boxeur vraiment et
bien vous allez jusqu'où je l'aï vu
blessé contre un gros quart de celle sur
internet et pas très longtemps
et c'est un traitement dit ça donc
c'est parce qu'il a il a joué ce conte
une espagnole un peu plus loose que
c'est pas une espagnole normal on dit de
haut niveau il a joué justement pour les
deux équipes plutôt que pour l'
équilibre des variantes traditionnel
[Musique]
boissons je trouve pas ça très inspirant
la position noir il a pris des risques
les structures d équilibre et j'ai peur
qu'ils se prennent soin grand rocks
autour des reins que le plan de 6 soit
vraiment difficile à défendre on va voir
mais ça ne paraît pas si facile cette
position pour les noirs ouais je ne déjà
pas les bleus n'ont rarement faudrait un
poids de mes crocs sur l'action des 6es
sort comment le défendre tu es tu là
come back 17 / congrès sur canal j 6
peut-être car et 2,5 il fait rage si ça
peut être possible mais c'est un peu du
tricotage en fonction c'est ça tient à
pas grand chose surtout l'un des jeunes
pression pour caruana sont volatiles
avantages de la couleur en rapide quand
efforts c'est important sur la caréna
impression curieuse sa décrue et en plus
ces cavaliers c8 se feraient vraiment
pas plaisir de jouer ce que serait archi
solide mais archi défensif et les blancs
pourront continuer avec des coûts pour
la prise des espaces comme f 4 cavaliers
eu deux cavaliers f4 bon bref il ya pire
plusieurs schémas ici mais pour
améliorer les pièces mais en tout cas si
on commence à faire car alice et 8 dans
cette position en magnésium on risque
vraiment d'être passif et l'adversaire à
toute l'emprise sur la position elle
devrait produire à petit comme ça
cavaliers ou mais une fois que dans ma
tête je peux faire cadrer le système
makhlouf où le cavalier au moins il sera
en danger pourra venir au centre cavale
et c'est ce qui est très triste
[Musique]
il est cloué à une fois une dame 17
pourrait ce qu'avait laissé vide ça
qu'on disait
mais on préfère la mettre à un autre
endroit que que ces huit si possible un
pack la valise six cavaliers des 4
alors comme ça qui va donner le fou il
va peut-être donner le faucon et
cavaliers aussi c'est possible ouais
c'est possible si
c'était
il ya plusieurs choses à voir mais
en tout cas en train de bloquer quelques
problèmes à régler pour les noirs vu le
début de partie
on a douze coups il y a quelques
problèmes à régler des
maximes à ben justement un petit mvele
cette rencontre qui jouent contre 1 des
compatriotes
oui oui c'est vrai alain pichat de ce
fait un moment qu'on le voit en plus
c'est ça beaucoup en nous que c'est le
numéro un argentin
emplacement fidh lent il a 26 30 40 donc
c'est un très bon joueur avec thé blanc
bon là je crois que c'est une position
presque déjà et je fais mon petit prono
qu'il est bien que ce soutien maxim mais
déjà une position à de résultats sans
doute
parce qu'il faut que kamerhe ce que
vous voyez le fou ces huit de la
française à
kiev bien coincé
davantage d'espacé est au blanc au
centre on voit un plan comme cavalier de
deux cavaliers des cas de se dessiner
moi j'aime beaucoup la position des
blancs ici
oui leroy hill et il est proche du
centre c'est une bonne pré finale moi
j'aime beaucoup les les
pour les blancs à la française mais de
manière générale et donc le maximum
qu'ils jouent tout cas c'est le centre
avec m6 qui aussi à peu près standard
tout ça
j'ai un gentil déception en fait si tu
veux ces femmes
j'étais parti du principe que maxime
n'avait les blancs et du coup je ne me
percevoir que pas du tout il veut pas du
tout par contre j'aime bien
pédagogiquement le coup joué par maxime
à m6 c'est hyper intéressant pour nous
là jusqu'à une position et à sa
nomination pour les blancs et en fait
ils essaient de faire du chamboule tout
en fait si jamais les noirs faisait rien
mais ben justement les blancs aurait pu
arriver avec un plan com com qu'il
disait ramener un cavalier en d4 est
vraiment bloqué le pont des cinglés tout
aussi bloquée
de france cela peut être possible et en
fait les noirs veulent pas être passifs
et qu'il est blanc parce ce qu'ils
veulent comme ça donc tout est
rapidement pour trouver 2 contre je donc
la case et les premières six cavaliers
g4 et c'est donc alors que aussi un pont
en prise avec prise prix des cavaliers
prend du courage de aussi qu'il est
souvent là
après faut calculer roi j'ai enfin ça
passe vite le bazar mais tour à chier ce
peut être c'est compliqué compliqué mais
on pourra voir en khl en russie ce qui
est qui devient fort si on arrive à
jouer 5 après l'annoncé dans ses
hypothèses là
sa caméra en roue libre la caméra elle
sait pas ce qu'il fait on couche et
empêcher un peu changé je peux supposer
sur sur nakamura mais j'ai réussi à
magouiller puisque le calme et je
réussis en avoir quatre qui marche au
lieu de cinq fois sur cinq majeur des
jeunes avec lui tout à l'heure mais je
sais pas ce qui se passe c'est un
problème je pense très clairement de des
caméras 2 de la fidh
en tout cas c'est marrant cette
française de maxime vachier lagrave un
conseil
très habitué de sicilienne
maxime qui change comment se prépare toi
d'alain monne france
était très critiquée par rapport à ça et
en ce moment il chante vraiment je pense
que c'est
c'est super intéressant quoi ça montre
toute sa motivation à aller encore plus
loin quoi parce qu'il s'est mis parce
que c'est du boulot il s'est mis à jouer
à quesnoy alors lui de jouer lagerfeld
il s'était mis avait dernièrement la
ligne jaune mais sanglant où on peut
tout jouer de son je pense
ils le faisaient pas mais maintenant il
va y va il va de plus en plus ça va
gêner si tu veux les 2004 2005 compte
qu'ils pouvaient des fois faire des
résultats relativement moyen parce
qu'ils jouaient pas vraiment contre dans
l'ouverture il joue et la préparation
adverse du coup la ccl mieux quoi
je crois qu'on va devoir
partir fanni tâche depuis
je crois qu'on commence à 15 c st-
un bain c'est possible c'est possible du
coup ils ont commencé un peu en retard 1
stéphane les partis mais nous oui le
mois dans un petit peu alors en fait
ouais ouais parce qu'on va t'on on est
on là des pubs
caisse comme et witches en partenariat
ensemble on nous force à faire des
pauses de trois minutes chaque
chaque demi heure et du coup c'est
malheureusement non choisie par un ver
nous reste la jaguar en discuter mais en
fait on discute nous qu'on a vécu on
discute et d'ailleurs n'hésitez pas à
aller voir nos chaînes respectives on
apprend là pardon seimandi avec avec
stop depuis le départ et ce tous filine
chaîne bat depuis plus longtemps que moi
un stream depuis du sud depuis combien
de temps ces drames j'ai commencé je
crois si je ne trouve pas je crois que
c'est mars le mars 2000 à 2020 donc ça
d'accord allant d'un an l'âge et
l'aspect deux semaines que j'ai un petit
problème de connexion on voit ses passes
trine depuis une tringle 22 semaines
parce qu'en fait parce qu'en fait
vas-tu et j'ai
l'âge de 8 ans j'ai mes identifiants sur
obs j'ai dû mettre duchess comme et
faire comprendre connectés nakagawa et
du courbet nous demande
de mettre seulement quand à moi donc ce
tous et quand je me sens de mon compte
et ben il me demande de vérifier
ma connexion sata avec mon numéro de
téléphone et mon numéro ma réponse armée
kibaki marche plus parce que je partais
l'argentine j'ai tout viré et mon numéro
de téléphone ne marche plus keller à
coulgens soit pas les sms donc j'ai
changé de numéro sur twitch pour pouvoir
recevoir de nouveau sms mais je n'arrive
pas à les recevoir j'ai un gros bug là
dessus c'est toujours pareil ça rime
problème tout y répondent pas quand je
leur parle le service adverse et en ce
moment c'est un peu la merde et mais
très bientôt j'espère pouvoir revenir en
tout cas je pense là début janvier là
c'est bon j'ai jamais la tronche et
astrid qui suit ici fait il suffit tout
simplement régler ce dossier de
retrouver de retrouver la chaîne
facilement donc n'hésitez pas et venez
vous savez un mois c je ne peux pas me
faire de so so c'est le le
la technique est récalcitrante ah oui
parce que tu as mis un petit 1
révolutionna la à
l'argentine je pensais alors que ces
évolutions
avec 1 1 p ah pardon oui je suis dans le
beh oui et oui c'est ça et rawlinson ça
doit être fait voler tu vois dans le
chat tu vois ça ça
et ça chambre un patou mono et on aurait
dit on était là directement
ça fait plus d'un mois c'est qu'ils ont
ralenti mais ça y est je pense plus
franche et
et malange géant tous au moi même parce
que il fait fort allez voir vous même la
chaîne de stouff twitch point tv slash
stouff
et vous retrouvez la chaîne de stéphane
ses fans amis les miens pour ma chaîne
si ça vous dit de nous rejoindre
n'hésitez pas à aller voir les replays
et franchement on passera un bon moment
quant à moi je stream énormément en
semaine
eux qui ne sont pas des vacances
scolaires est un petit peu moins pendant
les vacances même si on va devoir
beaucoup tous les jours là sur une
chaise comme et faire avec stéphane on
sera là tous les après midis pendant le
rapide pour la machine sociale le 1er
janvier ok donc en fait non on fait les
trois premiers trois premiers enfin
qu'outre en premier jouera donc dimanche
aujourd'hui lundi et de 15h à peu près
20 heures chaque jour sauf aujourd'hui
ça va durer plus longtemps je pense
qu'il ya une ronde de plus on est partis
pour doha l'arbre est par contre les le
championnat de blitz donc heroes qui ont
justement après du groupe mercredi et
jeudi donc 29 et 30 g de bêtises exact
exacte de la vendre et transmis sur tous
com/fr encore une fois avec cette
fois-ci par kevin bord du jet stream
dont je sais pas s'il aura un invité
probablement
mais on n'en sait pas plus pour
l'instant
et aussi à l' herbe vous savez que le
mémorable stream est aussi est aussi
retransmis sur youtube youtube duchess
com fr donc je vous laisse aussi à
l'éviter et laïque et la page duchess
com/fr youtube 1 vous serez toujours
[Musique]
notifiez quand il y aura des nouvelles
infos de nouvelles vidéos sur tous com
fr
bon bah c'est au top on a fait notre
petite prouesse qu'on enchaîne avec la
pub chaise comme histoire d'un rosier là
au niveau de la pub comme ça en disant
vous retrouve ou le dénouement en fait
de ce deuxième rapide était exactement
alors
je sais maintenant ce sont mes
téléphones en temps sur le chat la pub
donc les gars on se revoit dans trois
minutes à peu près pour pouvoir un peu
le dénouement de cette deuxième partie
du championnat du monde de rapides a
tout de suite des familles
[Musique]
et
non
[Musique]
et
oh
[Musique]
mo
et nous sommes revenus sommes de retour
alors qu donc bon vous avez suivi la
partie pendant qu'on n'était pas là donc
on voit maxime qui vient de cavale et h5
et donc ça a du sens saint clar en voie
d'adoption f4 qui est vraiment sous sous
pression mais on peut aussi par deux
pions ainsi donc en voix requis
à qui ça va vraiment en profiter alors
qu'avaient les fonds investissent ou
progressistes tout reprend aussi c'est
tourcoing f 4 3 3
j'aime bien les blancs gars à anvers en
l'air le temps qu'ils peuvent rapidement
fait arrivé à angers 6 hier ce plan peut
aussi tomber sa large liste rouge existe
cavaliers que tour emprise ça m'a l'air
difficile ok stevenson et moi sur
cavaliers prince 4 parce que on avait
l'impression que c'était
février première 4g j'ai pas vu mais ça
m'a l'air ok bon c'est toujours à six
sept tours à six cavaliers detroit ça
c'est plus facile comme l'ordinateur
effectivement moi j'ai pas vu près parce
que moi je regardais pas le redis j'ai
vu cavaliers première carte qui était
hyper mauvais temps et maintenant je
comprends que la tour prend 1,6 et là je
demandé à prendre aux
voix là ça embêterait çà
çà çà est en fait les blancs
je tentais en plus c'est tout d'options
sont faibles ça dit il
en fait il n'a pas calculé je pense aux
familles la justice et rugby 1,5 yvon
vallières h5 le mec pouvait pas prendre
réussi soirée du coup parce que c'est
une machine à calculer mvm mais il met
de la pression aussi autant donc bon
c'est en fait c'est pas si bête quoi ou
ankama clairement après à prévoir
après tu vois le joueur a créé blanc il
à 26,40 en vrai c'est vraiment fort
c'est donc il peut calculer forcé
puisque c'est risible pour le calculer
ça que l inverse l inverse 38 imagine
pas qu'il puisse le faire mais aussi
comme il est moins fort que son
adversaire qui peut aussi se dire par
lui faire confiance comme c'est très
bien on voit souvent à ce niveau là des
joueurs enfin quand est moins forte ou
dit ok le maquis voix il a vu et du coup
tu n'as pas trop envie de calculer
cavale et prendre ainsi ce parce que tu
penses que le mec il est du port jean
reprises près ce prix du voyage cette
tare est quoi alors que généralement un
plus fort va calculer 84 généralement
c'est ça et est à vue il ya robin saïda
qui disent qu'ils qui nous dit qu'en
plus on pourrait quelqu'un de cuir
cavalia trois chiots et il n'est pas
tendre avec nous et voudrait qua non on
va surtout en voit surtout on va surtout
voir si si notre ami tee shirt il trouve
cela et est en plus que le grec c'est
encore plus dur psychologiquement quand
je prends qu'un allié à chacun de
calculer cas les problèmes schiste mais
je pense qu'il peut trouver non affaire
me trouvais en fait c'est trouvable mais
bon c'est c'est pas s'il dans la loire
de voir cette série b 1 parce que ok ça
c'est normal car il prenait 4 ça c'est
le coup tu dis ok tu menaces çà çà çà
tout sur une découverte
et est ici l'an 100 km/h 3 tu fais quoi
du coup de froid je crois je dirais non
mais un point g2g passe web la tour j'ai
vite bon on a un projet de tour g8
peut-être tour g6 a comme ça moi j'ai
deux tours j'ai eu tout rejet si ce show
c'est quoi la différence
l'ordinateur est un droit g3 mais
j'attaque pourquoi
pas s'il y aura encore requins relief 4
sur le sco a indiqué à la fin
j'en crois j'ai deux tours g8 sa tour
j'ai six des 15 à 10 h 4 voila voila il
a tourné six marins se tient pas qu'à
briller h 15 voilà si je mens j'aurais
trouvé mais si tu manges là je mange pas
c'est qu'un des cinq ans et ça ça c'est
calme assez pointu c'est pas si simple à
en pratiquer retrouver
le trouvent et j'espère que j'espère que
robin side dans le chat il n'a pas leur
dire j'espère qu'il fait ou de tête
comme comme nous à tous
ses fans et on voit et on voit un stouff
dans le chat c'est pas moi qui parle h
30 cirque c'est incroyable et ça que tu
sois dans le char est en train de
calculer en train de faire est pas
vraiment ses menottes qui a coûté une
nous regardent
et robinson qui confirme qu'il appelle
ordi qui va en pilote auto
mais c'est plutôt sympa en tout cas la
position hyper chaude comme quoi on voit
que c'est c'est vraiment pas pas évident
cette petite variante et si on revient
on dirait qu'il a toujours pas joué
à y aller pourquoi un f4 et tourcoing
être caf j'aurai donc du coup il a
trouvé pilotes et maxime va il essaie de
trouver une variante qui tient le plus
mais je pense que là je pense qu'il a
juste il a dû voir que carey price 4
vous ne marche pas donc coincé il a vu
après une fois que pichot ahoueya
montrait donc qui chantait et brillant
et et maxime même si c'est mon poulain
je vous le rappelle ben je dois dire que
maintenant 50 et être dans cette
position contre un joueur de ce niveau
là
alors du coup ils ont un petit peu amusé
en parlant de poulin et c'est le mien ou
à devoir de suite
de quoi ses filles rosa avec avec les
noirs on a des paris de son âge là on a
parié quoi l'événement mais rien c'est à
toi de me dire depuis tout à l'heure tu
sais qu'on en a lancé dans le tchad ça
passe et rebondit et pour l'instant on
est un d'aceh je veux lui je n'avance et
proposer un peu comme lorsqu'on a fait
la dernière fois la valeur on avait
parié 5 c'est vrai qu'il me semble
vraiment tu veux on l'avait de paris et
on sait 5 + 5 banques est à l'essai
c'est normal si on arrive si on arrive à
0 0 parce qu'on avait un chacun bah je
propose qu'on se l'est pas et
mutuellement parce qu'on mérite
ok
qu'il y ait des gars normal et
donc d'un goy donc du coup le premier
pari c'est que alors donc toi tu
apparais que n'est pas arrivé devant
duda
non mais quand même drôle c'est que si
on parie un resto s'il faut aller en
argentine le faire ou que ce thème vient
me voir en bretagne fin tu vois c'est
mon boulot je ressens un restaurant
c'est un peu compliqué mais bon la tps
là je suis un petit peu loin c'est pas
quand je rentre je n'ai pas de date pour
l'instant ça risque de pas être grand
juin juillet mais peut-être bizarre ça
rien du tout en plus on risque d'oublier
ouais ouais c'est plus fiable plus élevé
car les pioline on la voit pas tant que
ça en finale parce que avant ce avant je
jouais singes entraîné aussi à cannes
les jeunes à cannes contre rhein sh pour
la france on pouvait voir de temps en
temps de temps en temps mais maintenant
tu entendras être plus à là dedans je
veux plus trop trop donne rien de voir
qui est bien en tant que joueur on a un
peu retraités en tant que joueur on a un
portrait qu'il faut le dire c'est
complètement venus voir ce fait
j'ai porté le point des bleus jouent
donc
bon en tout cas je sais pas aveugle et
blanc comment il a fait mais il a une
qualité de moi alors est-ce qu'il a dès
qu'on pense peut-être mais c'est bizarre
quand qu'est ce qui s'est passé ce qu'on
peut voir c'est parce que ça m'a permis
donc ok donc là les scènes avec g3 qui
se transforme en film sort finalement de
l'opl
qui avait laissé six dessins ça c'est
plus ou moins normal que son grade cette
théorie est presque impossible je
connais pas du tout
j'aurais dit que c'était le 4 le cros
normale
à la place de zeus et six noms comme ça
on le sait mais c'est normal le 4
mai alors du ku'damm ces deux je connais
pas c'est la surprise et il a pris tempo
sans doute hockey trop bien ça a du sens
lamoureux g20 ceux-ci se laissèrent du
sens en tout ça québec quatre vainqueurs
des simples à sa culture c'est à 60 ans
prend des quatre fous concernant bkc
fc3a la partie
ou c3
je prends la tour
donc c'est ma qualité de plus enfin j'ai
une tour de plus cela ici donc une
qualité vraiment affecté nous rackettent
risques humains
non mais sur dame beckham sous ces trois
cas ce qui se passait sur tour des vite
c'est peut-être ça le
truc
dont on débute la
non d'un bep cap et connais le foot
français 3 à ses fans excuse moi voyez
vous conduisez trois tours prend des
huit c'était le coup on va dire logique
dans la position
qu'ils mangent
voilà et tour prend la fuite cet état de
plus raisonnable quand même pour les
blancs ici qui peuvent peser de revenir
dans la partie puisque les le chien soit
un peu bizarre bottant un pour moi mais
mais bon t'as bu mais ça faisait
comme le k5 bizarre peut-être un peu
paumé dans l'autre jour j'ai quand même
des problèmes aussi en pratique tu as
aussi le plan c c'est ce qu'ils ont
prise et si t'arrives pas à régler ses
problèmes après avoir dû je vois la fois
les meilleurs fois chez sema grande
menace
raison nature raison ça peut être mais
il a trouvé bep cap des 4 enlever les
problèmes tu la dame va libérer
ces deux
là encore j'ai envie de poser une
question semaine à la place de fouet f3
est ce qu'on ne pouvait pas faire
d'abord dame c3 ont menacés soit un
chiffre de la semence est ce que c'était
de
5,14
à gaza mais elle n'a pas tous là je vais
oui je vais finir par vendre maintenant
notre pas forcément
il ya eu 5 aussi peut-être c'est la
diagonale et sur dame prend du coup tu
veux je commence
bien tout change le cavalier vain
pendant cinq heures a lieu à éric
carrière je vais t'en prie donc 5
donc 2,5 fois çi ça me faisait peur le
chalet pas trop calculer cette position
parce que x schisme c'est toujours ça
dans le pack ouais j'avais vu d'un prend
1,5
j'ai pas su calculé studio f1 et dams
est ici
ça c'est raté mais moi ça me
ça avait du sens mais là j'ai
peut-être tu peux faire un nom d'emprunt
france et beaucoup de matériel quand
même
quand on va dans le matin sinon facile
mais j'ai pas regardé le garder je
préfère regarder tu veux mais
ouais ouais moi je préfère pas regarder
ces pièces il en fait si vous voulez
quand on fait les commentaires comme ça
je préfère cacher les leur dis parce que
sinon je deviens esclaves de leur dis je
le regarde et bien sûr il est plus fort
que nous avec stéphane et on en devient
un peu ce club du truc alors que là
c'est intéressant quand même le
sacrifice
on m'a aussi malheureusement landais
nous a dit que ça a marché
c'est pas comme moi je le regarde pas de
façon égale en petit donc ça va mais moi
je ne
comprends pas du coup en fait dans la
nuque ont regardé
avait du sens ça avait du sens je
retrouve pas à lui qu'on regarde et je
les perds du
bon rapidement pour vous montrer
nécessaire dames 7 points parler de ça 5
de l'autre même parler de ça
ces trois dames d un toute la partie en
fait des cadres dans mes 4
et là franchement les 17 environ par les
dames c'est trois places 2 x 3 mais
c'est un meilleur quand on pratique
quand même ça on peut le dire
honnêtement
vous allez voir d'abord ce qui tisse et
ça c'est fort
quand j'étais assez content c'était fin
de mon petit truc dans s'isoler
franchement je te fais aussi des ouais
mais on va voir que c'est incorrect mais
je suis déçu parce que là il y à elia
2007 et surtout réaliste en fait les
efforts c'est en fait c'est ma les
formulaires de huit matchs donc la
saveur des mets fins ou ans et c'est la
première force et et apporte quand la
fin j'ai échecs et maintenant le tour de
recherche d'un coin sont sans doute
peut-être 3 2 où elle passe le jour à
o2i tu veux mais sa
fermeté mais en fait j'ai un problème
avec mon fou je défends le cavalier qui
m'a tour et j'ai quand même deux tours
et un cavalier pour la d'habitat et
m'ont rendu à l'île aux câlins qui s'est
passé ces jolis seins voyait
une dame s'est formé après son compte
les points 5 + 5 + 3 ça fait treize
ouais ouais j'ai pas su compter jusqu'à
13 facteur à me dire semaine c'est
julian mais je sais pas quand je n'ai
pas compté jusqu'à 13 et non à rester
bien des choix durs au calcul eh ben on
voit qu'une gaine de la dame pour 52
pièces pour s'est pas vraiment comme une
pièce ont à manger etc et des matériels
exactement et ses origines en calcul le
calcul est de vous planter un il faut
voir directement le sacrifice de dames
pour faire foi je crois pour faire tous
rêvent sept voiliers c'était dur c'était
chaud hein c'était chaud mais c'est
marrant c'est marrant belle petite belle
petite lyne voyer méchain peu étonné de
la partie de joueurs blancs comme qui a
un fort grand maître fort en maths
arménien a alors lesquels revenus dans
la partie
ces deux et au final car on arrive lui
hainard ont réussi à lever un bien
s'organiser oui donc là c'est alors qu'à
mettre une qualité d' avance pour il ya
hugo boss qui te pose une question l'un
j'imagine qu'elle est orientée sur quel
bookmaker potes ont parié sur la
compétition le relais je te réveilles à
la revue qui se fait devant la caméra
bravo
[Rires]
d'alors avant il y avait des sites sans
qu'elles ont crû paris mais c'est le
genre paris sportifs quoi sur l'échec
j'ai plus que mon c'était le site
ouais mais c'est que je crois plutôt
qu'on les parties lentes non nous en
europe n'était pas autorisé à parier je
crois il fallait un dpn où il fallait
vivre ailleurs
donc vous n'êtes pas trop après les
joueurs vraiment les plus favorisés
escarcelle nakamura
cyril ce serait
le format du tournoi le graillon on le
rappelle voilà merci saga c'est 13
secondes de 15 + 10 aujourd'hui il ya
cinq parties demain il ya quatre parties
et après-demain quatre parties sachez
que vous pouvez nous retrouver tous les
jours sur chaise comme fr pendant ces
trois journées à partir de 15h et gs à
peu près 20h 21h aujourd'hui c'est ça
alors est ce pour autant un petit peu
voire voir nos amis car elle n'a qu'à
mais on n'a pas vu maintenu sa honda
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas vu trop anus
assez dur de suivre tout le monde les
parties sont hyper intéressante c'est un
paravent ça va vite il ya beaucoup de
choses dont carlson qui a les noirs ici
qui a l'air à première vue de couvrir un
pote la tour qui arrive en dc 117
mais il ya le cavagnan f4 donc on sait
jamais trop à ce que disent qu'ils ont
acquis assez chiant qui peut rebondir
après ce qu ont scandé
4f prend ainsi sa peau qui me
qui
m'intéresse pas trop trop tourner en cas
de propos des cas de cavani en d4
intéressant que pour les tons doublé oui
tout tout dépend l'idée de f prince is
ça pouvait être de contrôler la case f5
qui est vraiment la classe naturelle
pour le cavalier blanche et 3
donc c'était aussi un coup pratique une
jouable
bon la dame des cinq magnus il va avoir
du mal à gagner cette partie
d'un des cinq avec les blancs ça va dire
maintenant de battre le joueur
c'est une position pressing que magnus
adorerais je pense des femmes avec des
blancs adamant ch s'entendre avec toi là
des blancs ou un bon petit plus un avec
castrés 5e puis on la sent que puissant
qui sont faibles et les clones ouverte
le 6
mai
alors parmi plus de 10 secondes c'est un
rajout de 10 secondes par coup à chaque
fois que l'on appuie sur la pendule ça
évite aux joueurs quand ils sont en
crise de temps incroyable en fin de
partie ils ont toujours se rajoutent
temps qui leur permet de finir la partie
proprement ça
ok bon on va casser une position
difficile
en détresse est ce que j'ai le droit de
prendre le point qui m'a l'air
comestibles un optionnel 5 c'est une
position et de résultat d'ensemble pour
les blancs
47 va sans doute essayer de magouilles
et après avec la rentrée du cavalier
mais
il n'a pas mangé le club a été 3 ce qui
peut arriver qu'elle valait prend b2 c
possède la chance de carrasso n'ont plus
qu'un petit pion en petite pompe dépasse
et
qui
disparaissent sans arrêt
on va voir
ce qui est choisie par le joueur blanc
puisque vous changez la caméra pour
monter car c'est un petit peu entre et
d'aisance tour des deux quand même un
très décevant pour moi autour de 2 c ça
prend un aveu de faiblesse dans cette
position
mais bon cela pèse 125 ça c'est quoi
aurait dit si cavale est ici qu elle des
trois tours sète au tour des simples
dames est clair avec le mur
j'aimerais mieux bloquer le cavaly mme
gerekou pas parce que tu as passé deux
tours jusque là je laisse ça aussi un
truc pas mates à tour ici pour bloquer
et
moi ça m'a fait un choc ce taux est un
vrai père s'en fait pas si protégé
chez packard a lieu trois toi de là dans
cette position en plus peut-être que je
peux essayer mais du coup sûr son tour
s'est dit non
tout va de la qualité quand
je pense que je m'en sors donc
quand je jouais à la halle avance
peut-être tour descartes pour éviter
tout cavalier c'est qu'un
très bon c'était hyper chaud c'était
hyper chaud à jouer pour les je
comprends pourquoi joueurs blancs il n'a
pas joué samedi mais c'était quand même
intéressant
y tu me casses les pieds tu recevras
chaque fois
non c'est vrai encore mais on peut
comprendre tour des 2,5 en fait plus
content champion du monde
il ya toujours un léger plus ici à
claques le couvert c'est
peut-être qu'ils lâchent pas voulu
prendre du risque
par contre ils pouvaient le faire prise
cinq avants cavaliers f5 peut-être été
plus simple non
je sais pas ça ça oui mais les
agressions prouvées de la pas fait
ça donc là du coup quand je pense qu'on
va avoir bientôt à 3h de arrivèrent
watch quatre
libère en fait je vais actualisé parce
que j'ai un souci il a plein de trucs
c'est qu'en fait ici sur g3 il rate en
cavale épreuve trois échecs et on
perdait le pont donc hk traquer jouer et
maintenant j'ai 3 et le roi vous voir
courir vers le centre de l'échiquier et
peut-être même le combiné faut
absolument gagner ce pion b3 sinon ça
peut être très très dangereux dans ce
grâce à battre au battement d'accès de
plomber 2 quand même et donc le pion à 4
et b3 qui sont plus connectés est peut
être faible on trouve ces victoires ces
deux aussi pour s'aimer pour ces deux
traits d'autres tours b 4 ou même des
produits réagir unis réussissent à tort
par toutes parts donc ils directement
les pions peuvent être faible et il faut
faire attention tout cavalier 4% voire 4
et 5 donc ya pas de tour des 5 pour
l'instant mais j ai savoir élisons aide
cinq partis aujourd'hui quatre parties
demain et quatre parties après demain 5
4 4 c'est ça
donc c'est du sport on a en est qu'à la
deuxième partie on vous le rappelle
le biais du sport absente joué par
carlson je vois sur la caméra
je pense qu'il veut aussi par gc ca fait
cavaliers dont il fait la même chose
qu'ici 1
5% et après j'ai trois cavaliers 26 des
une fois qu'on chasse de cavaliers
chacun dans sa case en d5 est un des
quatre
oui s'il arrive membres et cadres comme
tu dis là stéphane après il maintient le
client b 3
on a le sentiment que ça peut mal se
passer maintenant pour les blancs voilà
on a un seul tour b 5
avec les blancs ce qui est une bonne
nouvelle alors j'ai l'impression car ça
ne l'est pas contacté la grimace on a vu
il a raté ça
peut-être mieux et c'est à 13,6
en fait ses forces et tout ça c'est
balisé dons car c'est 2030 et la pendule
de 30 secondes en face
et
de quel tour à cette quinzaine on le
voit la salle
c'est pas mal est ce pire moment coquin
g6 pour faire cailler des cartes c'est
pas sûr parce qu'à cause des tours b6
pouvoir mais là bon jeu ce que je croque
je crois que l'option et après je fais
un coude et chacun un 8e rang j'ai cessé
qu'avec ça saute ça va passer la partie
de mon meilleur mais bon ça va ça va ce
égalisé son vote
ça n'a pas trop mal à une tourbe et 5
août où tu pars tu es mon invention il
ya eu tour et sec je pense que l'euro
valait 1 h 7 pour éviter les échecs sur
crédit et 6 il ya un problème quand même
sur des deux pions
donc oui quelqu'un simplement pour la
star ocean jolie sûr que quand il n'y a
rien ici parce que les deux planches il
plus active mais après en pratique on
voit le jour blanc à 25 secondes à la
pendule et ce précieux qui est facile à
jouer à b4 les cartes il veut tout les
excuses et un nom il veut égaliser 1-1
il veut égaliser
et nuala
est-ce que la nuit ça va plaire à magnus
non mais pas trop il aura pas de dhimmi
le choix me va quand même essayer
carpions peut-être y voir il va essayer
de continuer mais la fois que je crois
avec des menaces bay 5 ça c'est que ça
nous laisse avec emma cette fois c'est
risqué riche et qu'il risque est très
risqué ils mangeaient la d5 c'est risqué
aussi un
on me prend même b prend un sagan y
aurait un plus ha
oui en présence qui a trouvé cette donc
il faut absolument il faut absolument
ici pour
que je pense qu'il va je pense qu'il va
manger b4 et a prélevé cette dernière
j'ai comme ça il a mangé comme ça comme
ça c'est pas ma ainsi fait parce que
celles en fait il sait que c'est égal
mais il veut garder les pieds sur et
chili pour un hacker son adversaire avec
le temps arnaque et vous voyez ce que je
veux dire c'est à dire que il sait que
c'est légal mais continue à jouer aux
échecs
il ya une pression parce que clairement
la position allait
en fait la pression est légal mais mais
on voit que
du coup jouer aux échecs et mal autant
de femmes est de mettre un peu la
pression de continuer à jouer et faire
des pièges position vivante voilà
peut-être met à tour ici le québec est
rentré tout à l'heure on a vu un gars
aiment gagner avec tours fou de retour
donc pourquoi pas de gagner encore celle
là plus que son égal si chaque oiseau m
car c'est très fort dans cette position
est égale pour proclamer et là je vois
de suite que nos deux poulains duda et
aînés pour viennent de gagner tous les
deux hors parti
le mano a mano et est de 2 points ce
temps deux chars deux mais on a choisi
et on a choisi d'aider beaucoup là
franchement franchement on n'a pas
choisi n'importe qui
assez content ça va être le temps et pas
que du bon j'ai vu tout à l'heure saga
qui m'annonçait que un bel air et sauver
sa position difficile mais elle
maintient mvl a fait match nul je suis
il a sauvé devenu le salon qui l'a sauvé
je t'aime tant grenat un petit peu voir
ce qu'il a fait mais ton quand même 80
tours à 4 est vendu à 6 7 3
malgré tout
il a réussi à changer nous faut
ok ok bon comme max qui fait deux
parties nulles donc un sur deux nakamura
les filles rucka mourra alors on va
avoir fait route maka mois qu'elle gagne
fine avec un point de plus le roi est
coupée c'est ce qui peut être
il a posé problème entre blancs
carrément eux
à l'heure où es-tu fil rouge est
toujours dans les abysses retrouver est
très loin d'être un petit et de
salaire une gaffe on a carrément voir
mais moi il fallait trouver quelque
chose à la houe et dessus
et là qui va gagner affirme ou
d'année savoir si mais bon il était
gagnant il avait été plus oui on avait
vu un seul ce début apprendre à laisser
tomber mais quand même assez
impressionnant cammalleri mais voilà je
vous avais vu le marathon de 45 quand
même c'est incroyable histoire parce que
il va encore finir dernier
mais ça veut pas dire ou alors il a fait
un rictus à mon avis il ya quelque chose
qui s'est passé
c'est pas suivi du tout avec manu
savoir si tu veux non vie culte et doit
être mangés en live by de manger un 15
secondes encore à la pendule pourvoir
pour l'adversaire et manu s'il ya
beaucoup de temps a vendu par contre
il a fait le rictus des mauvais jours et
là on voit que sa main il n'est pas
content
mebara maintenant c'est une position de
travail pour son adversaire
voir il ya quand même des bonnes chances
des mulhousiens pas se mentir au pied
mais a oui oui il faut jamais mangé
jamais mangé h dimanche relate deux fois
se passe quoi
il prend pas
un cavalier reste 6 3 et 6 2 4 6 et 4 kg
4 cavaliers ou cinq puzzles a prévu un
carré noir cavalli rai 3 3
nuls sont en outre ces affaires des
besoins de lecavalier pour sentir comme
s'il veut ici oui là il y aura des
absents la voilà qui prend la faim
qu'avait le public n'est pas oublié le
temps un pur à chaque fois faut faire il
avait ça c'est facile là je mange ici
mondiale et venir à sa guise et contre
qui on ne voit pas de problème même ça
ça
f4 la f4 fini tout de suite
voilà je pense c'est ce qu'il a fait
n'est pas content magnus baril fait nul
à kiev 4
voilà pas de carson qui échangent tous
et qui fait nul
il a vérifié avec les blancs pour là
c'est de trouver quelque chose
à fait sérieuse et qui s'est plaint d'un
cavalier n'a même si tu perds un client
est
donc nulle signé pour qu'arsène qui
n'est plus à 100% depuis la petite
partie donc tu as un homme sur deux
et du coup je pense qu'on peut aller
peut-être suivre notre ami nakamura qui
a cette terre sacrée ans est plutôt des
grands maîtres à 2600 du coup il a fait
une grosse part tient
donc un nul mais à trop près
semblablement pour ça va être nul pour
la fin on voit pas trop
y'a pas trop piège normalement ici mais
bon c'est sûr avec mac amour ans on se
méfie mais bon là il ya plus normalement
de vacances et un pillage comme ça donc
voyez les deux joueurs qui est qui est
encore à 100% par les poulains un doodle
n'ai pas lâché on en a réparé voilà vous
avez vu la qualité des pronostics
suspense est ce que vous voulez
mais qui va finir en tête de la première
journée on a coiffé de prédiction
pour ce pour cela on aurait pu se battre
avec de chat pour ça et en tout cas ça y
est on a quasiment fait le tour avec la
partie
2-2 nakamura
il ya quelques jours meilleurs qui
jouent aussi on peut aller oui voilà
leur dire bonjour grâce à à peine une
heure on vous annonce un nul 2-2
nakamura pour n'avance une autre finale
pts qui n'a rien à voir non simple c'est
pas la même tendance à la gagnant pour
les blancs parce qu'il renvoie passe
parce que le roi il est plus le roi et
les couper pour que tu peux pas passer
en fait pour défendre à cause d'eux à
cause de la toxine roi noir avait été
hissé ce serait nulle sans problème il
aura noir est reparti de promotion mais
là que roy coupé ça va être la finale de
lui c'est la jambe le mans
et qui est la gagnante assez
tranquillement
oui la veille pas de soucis toute façon
va faire corps le roi noir et très mal
classés
glee 3 ici
là je pense quand même être la tour
derrière
ça
bien vu quand tu mets droit l'âge
heureux
non mais faut faire gaffe de passe ouais
ouais parce que ça va se faire coincer
des raynaud pions il manquait rien dit
mais bon ok ça
on voit bessette là et ses 517 combien
son tour la course est jouée c'est
symbolique donc quand il gagne sa partie
on invente un petit peu mammadyarov qui
a des noirs ici encore des finales de
tout renvoyer à un très récurrente ces
finales de tours agglo menace pour ces
six tours à 6 peut-être
on croit à 6 peut-être ici
ces choses cette position encore médor
lettre les deux pions voix d'alain sur
ça
la tension qui a pris adam sur l'échec
des fois
genre si sur rhodia soit
10,8
on va changer de fai retour c'est un
jeu de course 1 c'est sûr
mais peut-être que juste en fait selon
fabien
dont kg de sourcil un jouet
qu'est ce que j'ai comme plan m'a pas
grand chose
leur est tombée trois tours à 3 à 100%
laquelle permet de joindre pour
l'instant je vois on a caruana on a beau
je le connais pas on a un mur adli en a
mais pour vendre forest duda mon poulain
et n'est pas aussi un ton constructif de
11 ce rapport guelph en jeu bah va
encore beaucoup à paul keating titoff
et c'est donc est quand même pas mal de
joueurs qui ont qui ont deux points
quelques chocs aussi et puis c'est pas
finir on est encore en veut d'autres
joueurs qui me battre encore trop bas
sont deux
bons à la sava de les châtier chaque
classe a way
chaque j'attaque le pion à chaque
way he has ne vivent je vais réviser mes
finales de deux pions bah ouais deux
tours il ya pas un choix c'est grands
classiques aux échecs avec la tour qui
doit rester active et le travail autour
des faiblesses adverses on a vu trois
fin de partie 3 finale deux tours est
bon les mecs jouent ça vraiment
à voir que même le mec cool cats a fait
nul en raison d'un
différend niveau sa veuve on va les
battre pas de tout fait nul et si bas en
fait la dame va être fait mais après le
roi est trop loin pour empêcher la dame
en fait je vais faire ce que tu
vois là aujourd'hui vous voyez séraphin
la ronde 2 et on a cinq rondes à on
n'est même pas la moitié de la journée
encore
à la fin de cette partie
donc cette partie va faire un nul assez
facile
car on avait d'autres
alors on a au pari que je joue contre on
compare une blanc contre max d'oslo ma
d'oslo champion du monde junior
avec un qui est plus de 1600 que 2005
bah ouais ouais 2187 4 7 5 ok bah tu
vois où 95 mail et 715 et
puisque c'est le vélo rapide qui fait
foi et du coup il ya des joueurs qui
n'ont pas vraiment fait beaucoup de
compétitions et savièse un petit peu les
niveaux parce que la 222e 72 t'es pas
très contents de ce qu'ils jouent à 200
points de plus et aux parigots il a 26
50 fi donc c'est pas scandaleux ça voilà
ce sont ces foutus maintenant cette
position puisque toutes couleurs posées
mais n'at il ya deux pions trop forme
entropia arrive et c'est terminé ça va
être perdu abandon de yao nitoo quelques
jeux contre tarifs donc d'harry pareil
pas de 5 car on ne sait pas très bien
payé
mais en tout cas là il risque de
s'incliner parce que les deux pions
blanches sont très avancées ouais ça va
très très vite en 15 à 6 à 7 pour faire
une dame et le cavaly malo c'est marrant
c'est la deuxième finale mais deux pions
très très avancés avec soin à carole et
chacun soit un fou chacun et on voit que
ça va gagner dans les deux cas pour le
camp qui agressent
le camp qui à l'offensive ok
on voit que à très haut niveau un bien
sûr ça joue beaucoup plus en finale
qu'un niveau orateurs barret parce que
là qu'on s'est bien préparée et puis il
faut moins d'erreurs aussi un mois c'est
ça c'est constant et puis ils traduisent
l'avantagent en finale
notre notre ami espagnol shirov
oui c'est pas danser
dans les années 90 2000 c'était stéphane
hains mes joueurs préférés voir mon
joueur préféré parce que c'était tout
pour la pac shirov il est connu pour ça
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas parce
qu'il est un peu moins connus
aujourd'hui mais revient à un petit peu
sur ce circuit quand même et il a un
style caractéristique poser chaque qui
est pas évident au niveau mais il
envoyait
tout sur la tronche de ses adversaires
voilà il était très ambitieux dans le
jeu voilà d'ailleurs il a écrit il a
écrit une série de bouquins qui
s'appelait le feu tôt le chéquier ouais
donc par rapport à son site de jeux le
feu sur le chéquier c'est ce qu'il
recherchait avec grands
ont fait ça c est ce qu on est ce qu'on
a fait le tour quasiment ou pas le tour
et au massage escient qui joue avec les
blancs
apparemment je pense qu'on va arriver à
faire dame avant
un petit des cinq qui va partir on est
des saints croyais être oui décembre les
trois des tice dommage doc decaux
j'arrive trop vite j'arrive avant
et elle n'a pas de sortie
ce qui est pas de fioritures sur six est
pas de pions ici c'est faire sinon ça
serait d'accord une autre histoire parce
que là du coup il va y avoir f2 et il y
aura des échecs et puis à un moment
donné quand le roi va se mettre devant
vous par là je pense que tu as mangé cyr
mouais je pense que j'en fus
ouais c'est sûr mais sans sueur en
l'absence des pions h cette pollution
est nul ça vous connaissez normalement
le pion fou à une case de dames ça fait
nul à cause du thème de pâte
quand d'ailleurs avec échec quand on est
un f2 droit d'angers 2 eh ben je peux
tout simplement rachat à chaque fois et
dès que la dame mange un jour le pion
éveil rabat donc j'ai pas peur de perdre
champion f2 simon wright en h1 il faut
surtout pas mettre l'euro en f1 sable
ocre et de pions donc cette finale
cécile et des pions c'est tf1 qui nous
permettent de faire ce pas trop
dont un est
mais tout comme des pions ici safina
sera pas nulle part ce que je réussis
alors de norwich est en train de
chercher comment ça se passe histoire
qu'on raconte
une belle histoire
parce que bien sûr bon pour le court
l'évaluation est apparu mais je cherche
comment on arrive à prendre le pion
facilement
dans le monde
c'est quoi non mais j'ai pas vu le
hockey je crois qu'il ya un bug en gros
il va ils vivent à paris
on pouvait aussi jouer comme ça c'est à
dire c'est la finale de roy pion qui
gagne ouais
si le royaume et le voit été plus loin
sur ces gagner ça c'est la question oui
c'est ça c'est ça
vous avez la simplification là c'est
assez joli il a laissé faire dame pour
avoir une finale de pions gagnante et ça
c'est vraiment bien joué de sa part la
finale de pions
c'est une théorie que les pions tour si
le roi noir et sur la case de promotion
mais là il est dernière il est mal placé
donc on se fait avoir mais intéressant
de voir un certain pas ce qui se serait
passé si si si le roi blanc était ici
est ce que c'est vraiment gagnant ou pas
ca c
mais c'était pas si simple avec le pian
m2
où le roi dans la cadre à ce que les
moyens trouveraient sans faute sur el
cheikh
il ya le pacte tout le temps
moi je ne pense pas en fait que c'était
gagné ce que dès que je vais en h1 jonas
dame
ouais c'est nul à
n'ont donc ces voiliers c'est le
complexe aura là on est dans des finales
très spécifiques
ok bon bah on a fait le tour quasiment
de cette ronde de et on voit que ya déjà
de moins en moins de joueurs forcément à
100 % mais y en a pas tant que ça soit
mais ce que je mets le petit classement
est d'ailleurs un autre tu vas un
classement largement le classement on ne
peut pas vous honte à le partager avec
vous pour l'instant mais on a quand même
encore pour l'instant une une vingtaine
de joueurs encore 202
donc
parmi ces joueurs là on a noté doigts de
poulet pour 12 heures dépôt et
donc on va après ce qui se passe si
caruana aussi qu'on peut combien sont
pas cités il ya aussi de la revient et
reg asie parce qu'on m'en a pas parlé
ça maintient en fait ils accourent
edouard 22 gens comme ça l'internât 22
ans il à 2650
anfield ils montent comme une flèche et
damman il a fait des tournois donc en
inde
les le contour avec avec aronian et tout
ce genre là et je crois qu'il a gagné
les deux tournois et il a gagné un truc
du genre 150 points elo en deux tournois
en deux barres de plus pour rapide parce
que je crois si le blitz d'ailleurs est
maintenant en blitz il se trouve à 27,70
je croix sur le classement field et donc
c'est l'or est donc
donc c'est un genre que vraiment havrais
il faut vraiment surveiller et regaz et
balaye la ville à 202 et et il fait ses
preuves à chaque fois qu'il joue un
tournoi avec l'élite mondiale donc avoir
un peu ce qui donne en tout cas
d'exactions en posant voilà ça va
prendre d'ici trois quatre minutes cinq
minutes la ronde la ronde 3 de ce cher
du monde de rapides et on part en pause
comme vous le savez à chaque fois tous
les trente minutes à peu près
merci à vous de continuer à nous suivre
et on fait la petite pause via sms
stéphane envoyé à pied le ps a tout de
suite a tout de suite
[Musique]
oh
comment
[Musique]
m
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes revenus on
[Musique]
et est ce qu'il faut même là
hop
c'est un cauchemar ça y est on est bon
et on a pas que la route 3 stéphane il
ya déjà il ya déjà pas mal de petites
surprises pas de grosse grosse surprise
mais en tout cas des petites 1 c'est pas
si facile d'être à 100% dans on le voit
on le voit que c'est pas facile c'est
plus facile mais nos deux weave à nos
deux poulains on rappelle d'où là est né
peu massive à ce qu'on doit un groupe de
tête avec leurs deux points sur deux
tables 2 et 3 je pense qu'à la fin le
tournoi faudrait avoir demandé une
compensation parce que je pense qu'on
aura transmet un petit peu de réussite
c'est via ne le baril alors quelque peu
et un soutien moral à soutien à l'or
alors question est ce que les paris
qu'on se donnait est ce que c'est ces
détails qui qui qui vont durer pour la
durée de la gent re sur les trois jours
ou est ce que chaque jour on se fait à
paris
comment on fait c'est plus rigolo mais
on peut aussi vous y alliez le pari de
base qui est où l'ensemble du tournoi
mais il ya aussi ça peut être intéressé
avec
un petit pari journalier
temps on va la relancer en oeuvre mais
on a aussi une représentante française
qui veut pas du monde je peux toucher
les filles il s'agit de ninon m'assurer
des conducteurs va sur un petit peu
voire un peu de sa dame du faire un
petit coucou petit coucou
oui parce qu'en fait me semble-t-il si
je dis pas de bêtises sais pas si j'ai
bien lu de règles non c'était toutes les
joueuses à plus de 2250 qui pouvaient
prétendre à jouer le championnat du
monde deux lycées de rapides voilà et il
fallait pour le mix avoir plus de 2550
dans une des formes de jeu c'est à dire
que soit le blitz le rapide ou le lan
exactement donc tu avais ça et encore un
peu de travail pour nous ses fans mais
on
on pourra peut-être à terme je suis pas
du mans il y avait il y avait ces trois
conditions enfin une condition requise
pour participer ou alors être invité par
l'organisateur
compte afin qu'ils se déroule en pologne
personnellement je
connais tu le connais pas les demandes
et à mal car c'était un peu voilà et un
petit ouf
pourtant l'artiste ou faut pas qu'ils
abandonnent toutes ces pièces
il empêche pas de s'affirmer comme ça
j'aimerais trop faire après comme ça tu
vois la wii
fort logiquement déjà même rien fait un
choix de france de glisse moi je les
fais et j'allais finir la bulle comme on
comme on dit parce que je crois que
c'est les huit premiers qui étaient
qualifiées évidemment j'avais fini
neuvième mais mes entrailles et mais
c'est hyper bien de jouer laurent
frayssinet etienne bacrot tu vois ce
genre de joueur s'est déjà hyper
agréable et là le move ça fait rêver de
commencer à jouer les quelques noms jeu
de chaque set up d'ailleurs je sais bien
chez le top le top 16 ou 12 c'est génial
pour la chine a travaillé avec selemani
jova va avancer
c'est pour ça qu'on joue et c'est que
j'avais sur moi j'avais le championnat
de france de blitz était à nice l'année
et c'était en 2000
ouais 2000
2012 comme ça à 2011 2010 comme ça et
donc j'avais joué c'est chez moi ont
promis de le faire et domicile ouais et
j'avais joué contre etienne bacrot
l'avant-dernière ronde et il avait un
point de plus sur tout le monde bon moi
je suis derrière mais ce jeu parce qu'il
fallait qu'il joue quelqu'un
et j'avais raté amateur 2 dans une
position arrive est en fait à l'anecdote
qui fait mal et la partie dans la base
mais la barre si haut la main est rentré
il ya eu des bugs en fait atteint de là
on est confiant c'est un stade mais en
fait à en fait il n'ya pas la femme à
partie et puis là en fait d'un bug de
retransmission et aie aie aie a donc
géré à terme attendu en fait si tu veux
c'est marrant parce que j'avais tour
cavaliers et je faisais chaque action
alors que leur cavale f3 et cheikh
diabaté kscm et deux cases est sûre il y
avait une case que j'avais même par la
dette que c'était évident que je gagnais
et l'autre en fête ou où je pensais que
j'allais perpétuelle est en fête et ben
il m'a joué la mauvaise case et du coup
germanique et a plus pensé non mais en
fait on avait trois secondes chacun
ayant le sens de la paix rhdp tu étais
tu as voulu perpétuer ouais j'ai fait
des coups que j'ai pu pour le saut
contre le trou en fait
et j'ai fait une sorte de fautes de main
et tu veux donc prend rapidement dans le
money time comme ça t'as pas plus de dix
secondes j'imagine que tu avais quoi
rien n'est gravé aux secondes 3 de la
cadence
secondes chacun moi j'avais 2100 de
mille deux cents lots je veux pas trop
j'étais comme un fou que la châtre ou de
pater en tout cas et
j'avais fini pas en fait après le goût
que j'avais fait en fait après en fait
tu veux il avait déjà passé que t'es
trop fort - importations s'est abaissée
de mater un truc et une fois qu'on voit
c'est sa passe était revenu en force que
soit enfin les plus en avance greg
lassaigne seins et le sexe n'était pas
moi c'était sébastien mazet qui jouait
pour lui chiper le titre en cas de
défaite oui parce que cette équipe il a
blanchi 3 il y avait le gain du tournoi
et si je dépasse bêtise c'est marrant
que tu en parles c'est bien parce que
sébastien mazet et aussi dans le tournoi
je crois qu'il accompagne mvl et il joue
le tournoi si je tenais à bêtises je
l'avais vu alors je sais pas si on le
voit
puisqu'il est doit il doit répondre aux
conditions mais c'est à vérifier à ce
que j'avance mais il me semblait avoir
vu saint paul à
oui c'est ça c'est le voilà amazon joue
que le blitz et bains romains répondu
donc j'avais bien vu quelque part que
les jupes rapide
un feignant un feignant je le voyais
plus ce joueur rapide quand
on dit pourquoi
après peut-être que sur le sur les trois
en fait peut-être que le blitz qui le
voient plus comme un peu comme au caire
et création la tamise et breil et
l'oréal timide sur trois jours
peut-être qui les pousse là pour
vraiment été maxi donc ça c'est possible
en guinée a le droit de faire on a
toujours droit de faire ce qu'on veut
mais il est là vous le savez les joueurs
ont plusieurs statues le statut des fois
d'entraîneur le status seconde ans pour
d'autres et du coup il ya des
obligations aussi par rapport à ça alors
qu'un convoi on voit les caméras des des
jeunes femmes et et en un grillage qui
n'a voyage qui n'a
l'étoile russe un nom qui qui truste à
plus de 2600 lots
on aurait bien voulu voir faire faire le
mix par exemple typiquement par rapport
à ce que je disais tout à l'heure quand
elle est inquiète c'est dommage quand
elle veut un titre
oui oui je comprends après
quoi on en a fait des compétitions
mixtes mais non
mais pour du away pour du rapliq ebics à
titre perso je préférais la voir dans le
tournoi dans le trou à mixtes avec des
hommes je pense qu'elle pourrait en plus
faire quelque chose
et ferme à laquelle que quelques hommes
du crew ça serait vraiment intéressant
qu'elles puissent s'y coller après c'est
des choix donc est-ce qu'on va montrer
bis où il narre le glas du oui on est on
est un petit peu
faire des petits coucous comme on a dit
et c'est bien que ben on a une image aux
pratiques qui représente la france et on
n'a pas beaucoup on n'a aucune autre
représentante et on a quand même firoud
déjà maxime vachier lagrave à suivre
plus magnus carlsen aussi c'est toujours
un plaisir et autres parce qu'on a deux
poulains on vous le rappelle présenté
dans les différents tournois regarder le
premier sur la gauche acquiesce
je crois que tu as du bois un petit
doigt mais qui est plus sceptique lui
que cela en fait dans la dubaï l'a hélas
25 26 ans maintenant et oui oui moi je
les jouais je jouais il était 22 90 et
les dépasser 24 81 au classement suivant
vous à trois grands maîtres pologne
justement et s'était mal passé pour moi
je connaissais 22 coup de théorie et
connaissait encore en mieux moi alors je
sais tu es plutôt une des lignes
j'étais assez compétent nan mais déjà
été monstrueux en théorie est partout et
des très très bien préparés et bien
accompagné
ah oui arc arcolle on peut le dire un
bel l'échauffement mais il n'ya pas que
lui c'est à dire que firent hodja c'est
archi chaud aussi et c'est encore plus
jeunes c'est pour ça que c'est hyper
intéressant à avoir on pensait que
pendant dix ans encore maxime vachier
lagrave vous n'allez pas être trop
inquiété ou au moins cinq ans parce
qu'il ya des jeunes comme pourquoi homme
andré maori qui peuvent qui peuvent
faire mal un terme en tout cas il avait
quand même la mainmise sur les échecs
français et là il ya à lise réserve
frigia qui a été naturalisé français et
du coup ça nous donne une équipe de
france qui a une super gueule avec mvl
firoud déjà accro et on a aussi des
joueurs très forts comme jules moussard
maxime lagarde christian bauer et autres
et même pourquoi pas un retour un jour
de laurent frayssinet pourquoi pas ces
imaginaires on a aussi romain edouard
qui est dans les parages toujours un
et non mais on commence à avoir une
belle équipe de france
et c'est vrai qu'en plus ce tacle avec
l'arrivée aussi de 2
le petit morizet qui peut faire mal aux
siens ont été annulés tout à fait et
fait encore d'autres chaînes
oui marc coma terre il ya par exemple un
beau matin rien c'est là qu'est l'os
mobile est présente
je dirais qu il à présent si je dis pas
de bêtises 12 13 ans 13 allée la
question des migrations et l'eau c'est
pas mal la donne entre deux matchs crois
oui on va dire que c'est pas mal c'est
quoi ça c'est quoi ces traits fins et
les petits sont de plus en plus forte au
passé ils ont accès aux informations et
puis là on parle de jeunes qui sont
hyper hyper talentueux des hyper talent
du jeu d'échecs qui adorent cela et qui
font tous les tournois qui existe à dire
qu'ils jouent comme des machines ils
sont accompagnés par une structuration
au niveau assez souvent les parents qui
amènent comme les moyens vers des clubs
d'échecs fort d'être des fois aussi mais
il faut aussi un cercle familial qui
adhèrent à cela et c'est pas évident
pour tout le monde au-delà du fait
d'être très bon
et ar skol qui nous dit qu'il est
bientôt maître fide truc 300 points elo
belle formulation tranquille basterds
hanche 3 à 12 ans et demi tu as 12 13
ans on était pas mal cali
c'était assez logique
ça va bientôt reprendre yes et là c'est
assez intéressant parce qu'apparemment
maxime jouenne de la petite pépite
ukrainienne
je reprends je vais reprendre son
voilà
samuel koch qui est que 22 59 mais s'il
est que 22 59 et qu'il fait ce
championnat en en étant à un ennemi sur
deux clairement il est pas là pour rien
donc l'eau souvent c'est un petit peu
n'importe quoi comme tu voyais pas faut
faire gaffe faut faire gaffe à voile à
oued violent et très fiable moi j'ai
besoin est très fiable nous reste c'est
vrai j'avais vu un tournoi j'ai eu
participer le petit pride mandat
donc indien il avait quoi il avait 13 14
ans il avait déjà quasiment 2005-2006 en
feed et en rapide il avait 1700 et la
journée est noire il a joué un match en
départage pascaline tournoi contre
contre sow en départage ah oui et il a
perdu en
armageddon et le jour où tu vois se
perdre en armageddon contrat 1700 c'est
qu'il ya un souci
ouais non mais c'est juste construit en
fait
donc du coup voilà casser les lots les
autres pas trop les regarder en face les
lots rapide c'est vraiment
faut pas faire tant que sa confiance non
voilà larmes et donc la ronde 3 était
prévue à 17h30 et du coup on voit là des
marins à 18h vraisemblablement donc on a
une demi heure de retard sur le planning
ce qui fait que comme c'est tous des
heures 15 la la ronde 4 est prévu du
coût à 19h15 et la route 5 à 20h30 voilà
pour ceux qui voudraient le programme de
cette de cette journée de la première
journée de championnat du monde de
rapides et demain deuxième journée et
clôturent le troisième jour avec quatre
parties à chaque fois et demain et
après-demain et le 28 le 28 décembre on
se on saura qui succède à magnus carlsen
est ce qu il se succédera lui-même c'est
possible
et donc là je t'ai mis en première page
ton petit poulain avec mes potes ça par
contre on pourra éventuellement avoir un
aussi donc on a aussi des caméras sur en
fait j'ai des caméras deux premières
tables jetables ainsi duda et la table 2
g
mais bon
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal c'est pas
mal il ya du beau monde et tu as quand
même ça commence la faille callebaut tu
vois on prend un pari de plus dur on
choisir un joueur chacun
de rondo et les 200% évitables et 2
et ce qui est pas mal aussi stéphane
c'est qu'enfin enfin moi je me disais
que tourner poste hyper raid de repartir
après le championnat du monde qui s'est
très mal passée et là c'est quand même
intéressant de voir qu'il a un rapide et
humble x pour repartir surfray renonça
c'est bien pour lui c'est plutôt bien
parce que du coup tu as besoin de
reprendre un peu confiance en toi et
puis et puis un peu ça qu'elle est
rapide et bridge c'est quand même bon
moi je trouve ça plus sympa hein t'as un
thomas de l'île ce genre là mais il ya
vingt ans d'engagement comme ça
23h21 rondes de jeu ouais mais sûrement
jean bleach et belle tempête je joue
beaucoup et que c'est cool
pour lui ça va lui faire du bien puis
c'est un peu plus informelle donc deux
joueurs en glisse et rapide ouais c'est
pour ceux qui veulent savoir où ça se
joue ça se joue en pologne ça a changé
la dernière minute 1 c'était au
kazakhstan normalement accéder prévu ces
femmes ces têtes raides au kazakhstan et
puis qu vide ça c'est a été annulé et
cherchait un endroit pour le pour le
l'organiser et pensait vraiment
l'annuler et au final et ben ça c'est
loin d'accord avec avec la pologne et
puis ça se fait un peu l'oeil mais du
coup c'est hyper bien ça se joue au
final parce que tu vois les joueurs ont
envie de joe carnahan 50 ans qui a fait
le tournoi un potentiel que ça coûtait
championnat but c'est rapide c'est
quelque chose qu'on aime bien et
donc franchement c'est hyper cool hein
ouais puis désolé pour thoiras taxanes
offre pas en fait de place aux trois des
candidats parce que là c'est informant
rapide et glisse donc très spécifiques
je sais pas on pourrait le comparer
voilà une course de fond en rade les et
course de 100 mètres toujours en baver
c'est pas du tout le même le même jeu
pour moi j'ai déjà dit le vrai jeu c'est
le lent et c'est ce qui amène le titre
de champion du monde et tout le circuit
des candidats donc là non il n'y aura
pas de place aux candidats en jeu
et donc on attend impatiemment le
le début de la partie qui tarde à
arriver forcément c'est il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de
parties à suivre et parce qu'on peut
vous dire on a déjà fait un petit peu de
la pub pour nos chaînes respectives mais
n'hésitez pas à nous rejoindre aussi sur
le stream réguliers sur nos chaînes
respectives avec avec stouff sur sa
chaîne sur ma chaîne pro evolution échec
et on vous a dit aussi que sur le chèche
comme vous pouvez retrouver les vidéos
youtube n'hésitez pas à liker la page
youtube chaise com fr donc voilà vous
pouvez nous suivre très régulièrement si
vous le souhaitez et nous retrouver très
tranquillement et bien sûr là on est là
pour trois jours et il y aura du contenu
et là ça va commencer à fight et après
les routes 4 et 5 de ce soir je pense
que ça va être assez assez chaud
donc on passe du bon mois pour nous dire
ce qu'on fait sur nos chaînes ont fait
du jeu on propose aussi des contenus de
cours et on fait du divertissement
autour des échecs j'ai pas si tu vas
être d'autres jeux 3h trouve que que les
échecs non ça je suis pas trop rallier
israël mais je sais pas trop
mais on est complètement pareil tout
fonctionnaire sauf si je peux je vais
des
normaux ça m'intéresse pas du tout parce
que ce qui m'intéresse c'est c'est
comment dirais-je bas les et chacun sait
c'est sur ce sujet là avec avec stéphane
qu on est pro en tant qu'entraîneur et
du coup maintenant on fait en plus du
streaming pour montrer ce qu'on sait
faire plus de au plus de gens possible
voilà record effectivement on a fait des
petits prono on a exclu de près aussi
qu'on la remarque stéphane en a fait un
prono pour les français
stéphane a choisi ferroudja
maximale excuse-moi excuse moi
mais après moi ça me va très bien non
mais c'est vrai les deux mois c'est ce
qu'ils sont équivalent
anglais de ses rapides pour moi c'est
équivalent mais mais c'est vrai que je
te laisser choisir
qui soutenait entre maxime et des
raisins et tu as choisi de prendre parti
pour pour maxime
mais c'est phil rogers il est encore
plus favori je pense qu'il est encore
plus attendu maintenant mais ouais ok
mais c'est pas envie de maxime et décale
vraiment la cua hewitt où tout peut se
passer de façon dessin est bon la fille
rosa il enchaîne que tous les bons
résultats
tu peux avoir un tournoi qui se passe
pas forcément comme tu le souhaites ou
quoi franchement franchement pour moi
c'est qu'il va c'est vraiment 50 50
et en plus de cela on a essayé aussi de
voter pour
celui qui est notre poulain mais qui
n'est pas ni christen ni
nakamura et
ni les français
j'ai vu l'arbitré parler à duda et je me
demande s'il n'y a pas un problème
quelconque
pas démarrer derrière parce que j'ai vu
aussi une épaule se lever et qui parlait
avec christophe et ils sont tous deux
signent pas ce qui se passe ou un
rapport le rapport qui est debout avec
duda et
facilement poulain j'ai parié sur lui
aurait pour le gain du tournoi
on n'a pas le droit de choisir un
français ni de choisir une carte scène
ni nakamura donc à l'exception des
quatre joueurs eh ben j'ai essayé de
tenir duda qui se lève qui va changer si
doux de duda il est très sérieux donc si
il se lève ce qu' il n'est pas prêt de
jouer tout de suite tout de suite là en
fait ce qui se passe souvent c'est qu'en
fait ils veulent souvent faim laval la
table souvent on a réservé pour 40 cm je
sais que généralement chaque année que
tout ça car si le tableau 1 quoi qu'il
arrive oui et c'est peut-être là ils ont
dit va-t-en ckoi dégage
oui ça c'est énorme j'ai certainement
pas se regarder en tout cas draineur et
carson qui base d'un aveu la caméra 75
ans ce serait génial mais
ok je comprends mais bon on m'écoute d'à
côté
non pour moi qui peux pas faire ça en
fait un tête à tête je veux dire mouais
ça tableau c'est un bleu on peut point
je comprends l'idée dans ce cas il a
fuit 2
il faut qu'il faut qu'ils réussissent à
investir dans une caméra portative là
est
la 15e personne s'ils veulent mieux
l'aspect sportif avant tôt à ce que
sportif avant tout le show aussi c'est
important mais dans ce cas là il en
restait ce qu'on a fait ouais on est
d'accord chez nous c'est pas très
élevées m non mais c'est clair juste du
fait un bon tournoi dessus tu mérite
d'avoir ton et chéquier à toi désir
méchant puis sur d'autres journaux
anglais sont ils dangereux d'autant que
la stib rapide et ambitieux ok mais bon
là on va il a fait un sur deux pour
l'instant il ay l'a fait il a lâché une
nulle le rapport la chine deuxième
d'ailleurs c'est tous des stars en plus
c'est malouda il faut tout d'abord
j'aimerais juste enfin quitter internet
tôt pour dire bonjour à votre ami par
big sue qui nous a relancés sur le
stream je pense que tu le connais très
bien et oui là il arrive toujours à ses
avocats des leurs se doit donc de
l'injection au père mais nombre de
grands maîtres assez récemment plus les
normes de grands maîtres assez récemment
c'est le top 12
à la surprise générale en plus un peu le
dire
qu'on sait votre été
et du coup on ou non mais là il a montré
que finalement il avait encore y avait
encore des capacités importantes
ouais c'est cool ça nous fait plaisir de
la voir dans le chat ça nous fait
plaisir on dit qu'on a on a après ce
grand maître sur le chat genre
13 grands maîtres en devenir un
[Rires]
monstre
parce qu'avant de venir régulièrement
avant sûrement savons strictement monde
est invité d'honneur et un big band big
sue il en train de me dire qu'il ya plus
d loppement maintenant mais ça me fait
mal c'est vrai c'est vrai ce seuil il y
presque flux c'est possible en plus bas
à moi je suis vraiment retraité j'ai
vraiment regretté chez vraiment ce qu'il
doit être 24,60 je pense par là 70 c'est
vrai 60 km au dessus y avait une
quarantaine il a pris 20 points en top
12 april a lâché des points en espagne
chaque fois ah oui mais après la
première défaite si peu de temps dans
l'atlantique ça allait mal pour die
et
alors
sassou
alors de france est pour l'instant
ils ont un sur deux pour maxime vachier
lagrave deux matches nuls contre je
crois deux joueurs a quasiment 2006 et
un humour des pour pour ferroudja qui a
fait 2 nuls 1 2004 50 à l'as rome 1
n'était pas bien plus qu'un bien sauvé
est la ronde de il a battu un bon grand
maître
donc non mais
pour riza et ils sont bien partis dans
une demie sur deux sait vraiment où
s'avère un tournoi très très fort donc
c'est pas c'est pas du tout étonnant
tahir au chant le top 12 heures c'est
pas mal ce qui la fait pas tu s'est
passé pas mal d'amis il dit en regardant
je pense là comme il ya du talent au
mètre carré c'est parce que tu en penses
souffle et c'est une bonne remarque
que de votre sac à moi qu'il veut sur
duda
et recherche de place assise pour faire
alors il doit être fou hein
et revient à sa table on reviendrait
jamais faite celle-là
finalement tout va l'epic hs piquemal
chasse salut à toi et non n'importe qui
peut faire les tournois je pense que tu
avais envie de t'inscrire peut-être en
disant qu'ils répètent en pologne faire
le beats mais il voir tu attendre un
petit peu c'est 25 50 le ticket d'entrée
donc même barbe x ou peut pas encore
s'inscrire et pourquoi donc et pour te
mettrais pas
mais
non il faut vraiment vraiment du niveau
et même si vous êtes plus de 25 50 sur
chasse comme ça marche pas non plus il
faut que ça soit il faut que ça soit
réglé par la fidh tout ça donc c'est 25
50 soit en blitz moins rapide soit on
l'a
appris j'ai envie de m'en faire
franchement et le jour le jour où bars
où il passe deux mille cinq cents lots
barbichu vient de diamé verbe xx e minja
une bêtise il n'a pas écouté encore il
et 2500 rapide mais nous le dire ils
écoutent leur content et c'est que metz
et 25 50 on a dit c'est comme à l'école
tu vois il est coupable précisé après du
coup il fait n'importe quoi
non en fait rentrer dans le chat un oui
voilà 25 ans 50 c'est pas trop cher
savoir polito rappelle le faire mais
écoute bien voir avec s'écoute bien le
jour le jour où tu passes 25 50 ans
rapide
il faut pas de chez jesse conneries
comme ça ça peut arriver quand même ce
jour
eh ben je
vois tu
vois c'est ça va deux fois c'est
non non rapide c'est possible tu vois
ouais c'est presque possible sur un sur
un sale coup
c'est ainsi en week-end dernier énorme
25 pour lui quoi
déjà ah ça commence à léo la
basse est parti alors par mixer juste
pour finir un truc c'est pas de 25 50
allez je pense que je je je mets une
petite pièce de subventions pour
pourtant chocolat de du monde et je
pense que je ferais même qu est le
stream social de mega le parcours d'une
arme x justement je pourrais je pourrais
faire un stream en demande de soutien
pour payer le voyage à leur avis pour
son chocolat du monde ça pourrait être
sympa ça va je pense qu'il ya des
sponsors qui s'arrache serait quand même
les droits un niveau de paranoïa
scénarii a même pas quoi
exactement mais ils me disent michele on
ne balance pas les noms prénoms mais si
vous les trouvez dans le chat ou monde
ici vous avez bon et michel le prénom
c'est bien ça par contre attention un
arbitre c'est si tu vois super du monde
la bière elle est interdite sur
l'échiquier rien comment ils sont light
system bien-être oui c'est quelque chose
de sérieux c'est pas peut pas arriver
avec ton avec ton jogging ou avec où on
voit m tombe vide derrière je peux pas
rien et que la bière peut parier des
comme ça
ça dérive complet
s'est tracé sérieux et du coup de pic
barbie qui est arrivé dans le chatt sa
dérive complet mais les départs d'aidé
michel sniper pictures tu vois ça ça
commence et commence à y avoir
donc ça commence tôt que sept duda avec
les blancs c'est un de ses cinq missions
ou e3 c5
ouais il ya quelqu'un qui me demandait
tout à l'heure si mathieu cornette
faisait le tournoi non mathiot n'est pas
l'année par il aurait pu s'il le
souhaitait le faire mais
c'est pas si évident je suis pas sûr que
c'est toi qui tiens tu as vraiment
mathieu
championnat du monde bon j'ai pas la
période de l'année c'est compliqué aussi
c'est noël ouais c'est ça c'est
exactement c'est faux faux les dispos ça
reste pas trop mal an et c'est pas un
tournoi qu'il gagnera vraisemblablement
parce que c'est pas sa spécialité le bit
et est du coup bah voilà il faut qu'il
le fasse juste pour faire plaisir à
l'est en pologne où au départ kazakhstan
parce qu'ils fassent fait de la
ressource pour savoir que ça allait se
passer si c'est pour ne
rien jouer entre guillemets c'est un peu
un peu lourd pour quoi voilà ça c'est
clair
ok donc
je passe pas grand chose dans ce grand
vide à mme deschamps je refusais on va
les voir ce qui se passe bien jusqu'au
f5 hockey semble que c'est ça que
c'était vous prenez
me le font bekaert déjà avec le carillon
f3 donc
j'avoue je sais pas regardé l'heure de
cours nous faisons un gorille d'amr
agouazi le départ ouais
parce que c'est que souvent je vois que
des plans comme ça il y en a 5 à 7 et à
pékin 24 ce genre d'idée
normalement
là on dirait un mix entre à entre une
ragots zine et un grand vide à me
refusais classique tant d'arbres
parce qu'il faut c'est la question ces
dames b3 la question aussi peut-être
petrochem
général qu'on le pousse et 8 sort via
youtube et soft qui en l'air et du coup
c'est toujours la question mais bon
parce que du coup est-ce qu'on peut être
parce que le chameau ce bien un truc
comme ça j'en reprise prise damas cinq
peut-être à mieux apprécier tout en leur
nom ouais c'est ça c'est sur la question
c'est que mais il ya des g5 on sait bien
donc c'est compliqué cette position on
va on va bien voir là on peut faire un
petit tour des stades un petit tour des
échiquiers pour un bon début donc on va
voir ton couleurs à toi
c'était plaisir j'attends avec sa hanche
a dû malheureusement on n'a pas des
forfaits acquis c'est bien ainsi
alors donc ça s'est séparé ces ironies
mesure il ya notamment quatre échecs et
de fonder quatre
mois c'était la même c'était ce terrain
voisine encore donc la france qui me
guide et noir sept jours plus tard 5 1
je ressemble 5 après je suis pas du tout
à ce pc 7 de ses ouvertures j'aime pas
visuellement d'un cadavre un carré ans à
6 j'aime pas oui comme il en faire le
saint qui se dit que c'est peut-être pas
trop grave
menace est relié à des petites
maintenant c'est calme allait prendre
les cars qui viendraient fut 17,8
tourner vers sa
joie rien de spécial pour l'instant
alors vite dit à 26,29 qui a aussi vécu
2007 faut savoir c'est sûr voilà vingt
ou trente ans fitch group d'atouts et
voilà même pas mais webs entre 15 et 15
étrangers dirais qu'à un joueur qui
monte qui est très prometteur très
sérieux et
ce qui se passe quand je pense qu'ici
trois résultats sont possibles
non mais n'est pas je suis vraiment
content de crise qui jouent vraiment
extrêmement vite quoi et comme il a été
piqué avec le champion du monde qui
s'est mal passé c c'est franchement
franchement
cherché content après dubaï n'a pas
l'air à 6 inquiet sur la caméra
franchement il a l'air de bien maîtriser
son sujet mamadou d'asselah latéral qui
est vraiment fort dans les trois cas
dans ce sens aussi c'est un peu comme
des pots
genre tout choc en blitz moins rapide ou
en lan en fait d'être aux commandes s'il
est vraiment l'accord amiable comme
rhône alpes avait un point faible en
blitz par l'ue contre carlson et je
pense c'est un truc aussi stéphane c'est
l'histoire de pub parce que du coup
comme tout a été décalé et qu'on est
resté discuter j'ai besoin je dois pas
lancer une flèche et qu enfin en fait la
pub c'est la pub 2 c par rapport à
twitch la pub c'est pas par rapport à
szczecin auxi le pas par rapport au
parti c'est par rapport à part rapport
c'est le temps on en sait autant c'est
autant qu'on attend des heures à peu
près donc je pense que je pense qu'on
n'a pas fait assez de cugand fait et ça
ça m'énerve a changé ça me saoule des
pubs mais encore une fois je vous
rappelle les gens
les pulls qu'on fait en fait parce qu'on
est imposée par tweet chasse comme a eu
un contrat avec twitch et arrête
maintenant on est imposé on doit
absolument mettre débout des poussins
chaque demi heure on met trois minutes
de pause c'est obligatoire et c c'est
pour trick donc malheureusement les
pulls que nous
on installera sur sur
twitter c'est pas de notre volonté c'est
vraiment ces fonds pour mal parce que
comme ça a pris un petit peu de retard
c'est une au milieu une à pain mais
comme ça a pris un peu de retard on va
être obligé de dakar une je pense
qu'aller bon du coup je vais on se
revoit tout de suite les arias on nous
fait juste les trois minutes de pub
réglementaire ouais et puis c'est
reparti après pour pour ces partis
d'houdain epoca 100 pieds rouges à mpl
et les autres yes et c'est parti a tout
de suite on ne partait pas rester bien
là
on se retrouve dans trois minutes
exactement
[Musique]
m
et
[Musique]
du
en
[Musique]
bon
nap's co kkr on dit qu'il a pas les
airs bonjour à tous on est revenu on est
de retour
qu'au cours les amis donc dans la partie
de
là on était sûr visite est né peu un
caméra de duda change rien que ça donc
on voit que il ya une présomption de 4
et
pas facile facile à avant ce qui se
passe parce que j'aurais plus captivant
et peut être en prise et cheveux si même
des phases relief 6 3 devant jose
quelques attaques là te rend possible
voire fou 8 a été joué ainsi pour contre
les cases le qat ger 6-2 transgenres f6
j'aurais pas qu'elle reste des coûts
et pour les pour eric vient le temps des
joueurs maintenant c'est juste qu'on
était passés en mode pub donc d'un coup
ça avait une autre gamme c'est juste
pour la petite pub pour moi j'aime bien
les noirs un sa position en cavale et il
est très bien en ses cadres on va
remettre six les plombs blanc 115
blanche ce qui fait que le faux 2 qu'une
mauvaise pièce et le fou l'acception
revenir après en bourse c'est l'asvel
position de contre bâle position de
contre pour tourner court en fait et le
centre blanc une fois qu'il est cassé
bah il ya des pièces noires qui vont
s'infiltrer et on a balancé les pions cf
ça va être faiblard et en pouvoir aussi
le niveau de temps que ce que nous
espérions de réfléchissement pas du tout
un peu comme dan et donc il encore 16
buts à la pendule on commence à 15 + 10
1 et il a de plus de temps maintenant
que je sais que quand il a commencé et
vite combien sont enquis très sérieux et
un est en fait oui qu'ils nous demandent
pourquoi carlier ans par qu'ils ont
prise parce qu'ils se demandent s'il
faut pas manger gras tour le cavalier et
si ça peut paraître du détail c'est
justement ce souci du détail qui fait la
différence entre ces joueurs de haut
niveau avec l'aspect calcul derrière
juste mieux posté une pièce des fois ça
peut être les problèmes majeurs pour
l'adversaire a à régler donc ce sont des
décisions très importantes et
vous le voyez peut-être pas mais on a on
a comment dirais-je sur sur votre
interface la précision des coups est née
peau pour l'instant il ya plus de 99% de
précisions sur sa partie
sachant que il lui a aussi croqué au
niveau du temps sept minutes c'est du 15
+10 dépôt il a quinze minutes 15
secondes vous voyez là quasiment pas
gaspiller de temps il a un plus bas
voilà plus de 2,9 sur dix sur ses coûts
donc c'est un véritable monstre et je me
rappelle c'est pour ça que j'ai choisi
de mettre une petite pièce est sûre
d'ailleurs on va on va vite aller voir
ce que nous faisons traduit duda ce que
je vous rappelle qu'on a un petit part
et entre avec kevin sur celui qui va
faire le meilleur score entre duda et
entre duda un dépôt et des recettes et
l'on peut même rajouter un petit paraît
sur le résultat de la partie entre ces
deux joueurs s'ils s'affrontent ah oui
oui et ils risquent de s'affronter un
jour
dès qu'ils jouent ensemble des qui joue
ensemble on se fait ce pari là juste en
direct avoir un parti parce que c'est ça
c'est ça qu'est fonction prévoit c - moi
je vois j'ai les façons ils vont se
jouer un jour probablement quand même
j'espère j'espère s'ils restent devant
les premières tables a donc là ici on a
l'impression qu'à pas énormément évolué
entre 12h c'est pas très rigolo pour
l'instant
est prenable mais qu est ce parce que
qu'est le tour b 8 manger des deux
serait de derrière et aussi donc prise
prise prise prend b2 tranche de 20 kg
sens là il ya le faux de toujours on est
ok du jeu
bon il ya 10 g ça donne pas envie de le
prendre dans ces conditions la ram et
après peut-être améliorer le spot
comme on a vu duda on a vu
l'année les pros est ce qu'on pourrait
faire un petit tour
on voit que c'est pas un chacun j'ai
défoncé
déjà féminin a fallu le très très nette
avec les noirs contre halkia ce pour ça
qu'un grand maître
ouais thonon donc ok mais on a comme moi
ta main mon père théorique en plus ça
c'est très théorique
position
répétition ok ok je comprends qu'il est
noir que sa cote est bon
ça lui fait combien ils arrivent ils à
deux nuls non agréé il ya un nul nul
donc là 200 points c'est ça ils vont
trouverez sur trois petits départ pour
l'un des grands favoris mais bon après
deux sur trois y a pas de catastrophe il
apparaît d'une partie bon oui mais du
coup il aurait dans la prochaine
il faut qu'ils fassent
3,5 je pense pour une première journée
comme ça vous restez ce qu'on voit que
les très très forts font quand même des
scores astronomiques danser dans cet
endroit là donc
et quinzaine il adore ses positions la
cfu le pic rails de la paire de fou
stoffer vers l'avant
[Musique]
c'est une boisson qui savait pas quand
même un peu à la partie qui la jouent
contre des pots la famille politique a
duré huit heures c'est vrai la structure
par rapport à la terre de feu
tu as tout à fait tout à fait raison là
il ya il ya un faux qui ont de plus en
fait pour
pour les pour les noirs parce que les
blancs récupère un peu comme ils veulent
par exemple vous pouvez déjà faire faire
des choses comme fou c'est cissé est
récupérée récupérer les cinq des choses
comme ça bon il va essayer de le faire
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
mais c'est vrai que c'est une position
de travail position qu'on appelle à deux
résultats quinzaine très forts pour ça
c'est les échecs moderne avec les blancs
c'est à dire qu'on joue pour la petite
amélioration lente
et c'est vraiment désagréable de jouer
ce genre de position avec des noirs quoi
drief pour serveurs qui est à 2007 1
donc c'est très fort mais il est quand
même plus sur la fin que sur le début de
sa carrière donc il va se faire secouer
par quinzaine et lacs et des rivières
d'ailleurs il ya quelques
très bonnes questions et je vais la
laisser donc au chat cette question a
négocié avec cette brillante au canada 6
à
55 60 ouais les 56
j'ai tout donné oui la récupération de
ce souffle en direct live
mais bien joué souvent bon jeu dure 52
59 non mais là je pense que la même plus
60 que 59 oui moi je pense aussi c'est
ça gagne 1,59 tranquille chez c'est un
peu de marge pour coller à 57 je vois
qu'ils me disent ouais tu colles
un petit 59 en disant que je devais être
je devais être bon j'ai pleuré 6,57 bien
évidemment
lorsque nous dire qu'elle a 50 de non
sérieux
52 ça fait 20 ou peut-être qu au lit tôt
ou tout simplement un amendement
50 de temps j'aurais dû plus à
damas a du coup ça me ferait perdre
heureusement qu'on n'a pas fait de petit
paris là dessus mais elle a épargné dans
donc on va dire non mais
en tout cas dans le chat ça suit merci à
vous on voit qui en a qui sont qui sont
au top qui sont autant est-ce qu'on
n'irait pas avoir de petits frenchy y
ait ce qui freine jusque là aussi paris
sur les petits vous savez que le poulain
de stouffs et qui roulent déjà
et mon poulain
cmv cnvl
clairement j'ai choisi
alors jusque là 35 c'est une sorte de je
pense un caen b dames standard ça
voulait où les noirs commencent à
pousser f5 et 5
ouais mais alors à t'envoyer des choses
bizarres quand même parce que le fou g3
a été échangé donc s'est passé quoi je
regarde simplement des bus de londres on
a débuté vendredi à vos idées
alors il me semble il me semble
j'avais pas cependant que ça j'ai eu
thomas déjouer sa
place en manche
et d'anecdotes après un cru par là il
n'a pas obtenu grand chose l'impression
et les noms commencent à pousser le
plongez donc plus tard et des idées qui
peuvent arriver avec g4 et ramener la
tour sur h6 et les matins à chiens voilà
comment profit de la côte aggrey blanc
sera dur parce que le coût d ici six
tient tout à la case the saints qui
avaient bien tenu aussi
franchement c'est pas si facile que ça à
jouer avec les blancs
ce n'est pas une des transcendances ben
en fait quand tu vois que non en fait
j'ai 5 et 5 tu as enfin tu sens un petit
peu le jeu des noirs cette position de
comment ils vont faire quelle est l'idée
générale mais c'est vrai que si les
blancs tu as plus de mal parce que tu
peux pas dans le cinq cavaliers là il va
jusqu'à valais berne pourquoi qu'avait
divers gauche m j'aimerais trop mal mon
cavalier e 5 mais c'est pas possible
ouais des coûts
cavaliers h4 été jouée ici c'est normal
pour moi parce que sinon il y avait un
chien cash car ça reste cher détruire
avec les blancs notamment aux carmes à
10 h 4 je trouve ça normal il faut
bloquer maintenant j'ai peut-être une
idée tout rêve certes cavaliers fut 2 kg
pourquoi pas lecavalier 6 pour échanger
et est ce que tous devraient ouvrir la
semaine à la soirée risque d'être
directement dans le mid et c'est plus
précis c'est fou parce que même tour est
aussi ce tour hcc mène peut-être un
monde je voudrais ça fait peur je suis
d'accord pour 3h 4 puis on prend d'un
point à 24 ça peut faire peur qu à main
ouais il a joué dame g5 là
je pense qu'il est mauvais
les pièces tout à tour le cavalier mai
franchement ça fait hyper peur à gré
blanc j'aime pas eu lieu
en pratique rapide je pense que firent
où déjà il préférait largement à voir à
revoir les noirs c'est une position qui
est on voit bien joué
j'ai pas aimé skoda mais sa maladie est
parce que l bah ça va la plus logique de
faussement c'est que ça a l'air la dame
les saints qui ça fait quoi en fait ce
coup là ça ne passe pas grand chose à
tête dans le set donc je libère m à gaza
s'ils cessent que je référence cavale et
les sicav et de 4 par exemple plus tard
dans certaines positions peut-être un
fou prend g3 de l'espace avec d'un point
trois échecs mais c'est vraiment pouvoir
justifier un coût qui n'est pas pour
l'instant mais pour l'instant c'est pas
une ménages s'était par manquement beau
rien comme tu sais maintenant que féret
mais ça va je trouvais plus ou pour m6
en fait tous merci ça m'a l'air mieux
parce que tu as plus d'idées en fait à
l'idée de fenaille avaler la tave aussi
devenir en justice pour rien
sacrifier l'attend contre le cavalier et
puis bon ça m'avait un peu logique après
la guerre c'est pas du tout
ok c'est une belle belle bon système en
tout cas proposé par les 20 les noirs
clairement enfants à saint parres d'ascq
assez drôle c'est que l'ordinateur
propose d'amener cette
île se trompèrent meilleur qu'août à me
7,2 mrds md83 à mérida merci
donc à raison que en fait beaucoup
d'amis g5
on a ces accords sont elles que c'était
un peu bizarre après en pratique ça va
quand même être intéressant cette idée
en
bref si sur un cheese toujours là non
mais ça je parle ou encore je peux même
des fois on s'est un jour même si de la
mère
la fille rousse déjà pour l'instant
d'aller parti qui nous a montré
c'est un des plus grands espoirs à
l'échelle mondiale mais pour l'instant
il n'a pas fait une journée
extraordinaire on va voir ce qui va
faire dans cette partie ben pour
l'instant sur deux la finul 1 il a fait
nul 1 1 2450 c'est ça c'est pas lui
c'est non pour l'espagne surtout que là
avec les blancs il n'y a pas il n'a pas
déjà pris davantage alors que l'on
pourrait s'y attendre quand même contre
un joueur
petit gm
y est ce qu'on peut aller voir
amv l'ouest s'y attaque simulée noir
donc là on exalte bien échanger votre
maxime mais je voudrais mettre fit qu'à
22 59
donc ok donc je sais pas combien de
vélos il a
poussé tu vois il a quand même des lois
assez bas mais j'imagine quand même que
ce jour là pour participer
alors c'était pouvait certes toujours à
lens c'est un tout jeune joueur assez
agaçant m
il a 12 ans il ya douze ans merci à toi
flavie tôt pour l'abonnement
donc là je pense qu'il risque qui en
fait le joueur il a grêlé chauffer une
invitation une wild card du tournage de
son classement ouais d'autant plus que
l'ukraine ce pas très loin de la pologne
connaissent leurs sénateurs ou la
théorie
voilà mais là il va souffrir il va
souffrir contre nv qui a vraiment une
position voix de résultats à position
somptueuse de travail le faut si c'est
une pièce très simple et bref il est
très très fort et bloque le pion 1,5 la
case f7 contrôler les pions à 4 et
brison menace fn
c'est pas évident pour les blancs
d'éléphants truc tout ça mais c'est pas
nécessaire nécessairement triste qu'un
joueur de 12 ans soit aussi fort parce
que faut pas comparer et l'huile a
commencé très tôt les échecs il est
hyper talentueux et vous pouvez prendre
du plaisir même sans avoir
à 12 ans le niveau qu'il a voilà ça
dépend quand l'investissement dans la
discipline je peux vous dire pour être à
12 ans dans ce niveau là à ce niveau là
au delà d'être hyper talentueux c'est
aussi une bête de travail anses a c'est
ce qu'il faut bien mesurer et vous des
fois qu'ils voulaient être fort aux
échecs des fois vous n'avez pas le temps
à allouer suffisamment parce que vous
avez votre vie de famille parce que vous
avez d'autres activités parce que vous
avez votre travail mais ce qui vous
empêche pas de faire oublier sur ce
point comme de prendre du plaisir vous
inscrire en club aussi pour les plus
motivés d'entre vous donc voilà chacun à
chacun peut peut trouver du plaisir à sa
mesure donc c'est assez pas un problème
c'est plutôt sympa de voir ce genre de
jeunes pousses là et de voir ce qu'ils
vont devenir réellement parce que dans
ces jeunes talents hyper talent à 12 ans
il ya des trajectoires différentes on
voit des fois des joueurs régaler après
plus tard ou pas du tout mais clairement
clairement et donc en basculant entre
temps tous les cas c'est cool de voir
des
de ses jeunes joueurs comme ça
au top niveau ici là on voit capture
maxime n'est pas serein et c'est
finalement d'un coin hcc comme une
menace aux règles cavale et prend 1,3 va
devoir être le coup joué l'un parce que
ça peut être voir ouais j'ai 5
cours et donc avaler pour en apprendre 3
etc m
voilà pour moi c'est plus facile quand
même coach et noir mais pas encore
gagnant bien surtout des pions sont un
peu faibles
chacun fut le roi noir il peut avoir des
problèmes à maman donc votre chance à
gafas la
presse ça tu fais quoi
j'ai 5
jean n'a joué aucun 3g celle ci s'est
dit
jamais je veux c'est vrai que en fait
faut aucun droit g7 tu restes avec des
problèmes en fait c'est vrai que c'est
assez incroyable
en fait un objet sans qu'ils jouent plus
souple et qui te laisse choisir et s
connaît bien joué et c'est très bien
joué voilà pourquoi en fait nous on
n'est pas de 1700 ouais parce que j'ai 5
vous voyez souffle l'avait rejetée parce
que c'est assez normal visuellement le
roy on achète on n'a pas envie de
l'ouvrir mais maxime la considère que le
roi je sais ça allait ou en fait il le
laisse avec ces problèmes quand on a
expliqué stéphane donc c'est que c'est
clair que ce c'est fort l'eia pas la
caméra de maxime nana là que la caméra
de l'échiquier numéro 1 passe et 1 et 2
j'ai pas plus donc temps que max ne joue
pas aux dés demain l'abonnement je peux
pas vous montrer donc l'âge et que tout
d'abord mais
c'est ça se mérite d'être d'être sur la
caméra d'une chaise comme f1 soit vous
êtes un bleu un saut vous n'êtes pas sur
la caméra quoi ça c'est clair ça très
normal les joueurs du coup ils vont se
battre pour être sûr la caméra voilà ça
on peut le dire donc
on est
on est pas mal ici on est pas mal avec
avec baignoire je pronostique une petite
victoire de maxime prochainement là
ouais ça va quand même des problèmes
après ça va dépoter tout est un peu
faible ici est assez et d'un certain âge
on va voir comment
vont être mis au travail il ya 2 minutes
30 pour les blancs entrevue minutes
c'est quand même pas mal pour un combat
que je pense qu'elle est on va
ouais c'est la troisième ronde de la
journée il y en a cinq aujourd'hui 4
demain à partir de 15h et 4 après demain
pour décider du type de champion du
monde de rapides en cadence 15 plus
disent tiens stéphane est ce qu'on n'y
avait pas voir juste un petit instant si
tu la trouves nino maisuradze et qu'on
n'a pas été voir jusqu'à présent ouais
alors je vais changer tout à l'heure à
trouver parce que là je suis dans la
masse des trucs mais t'inquiète pas tu
rencontres de seconde au lycée pour
l'instant j'en fait d'accord de tournois
que j'aille dans le championnat féminin
qui se trouve justement du travail à je
te donne du travail à ses fans non non
ça va on regarde si ça évolue page chez
maxim mais le joueur craignait des
petits problèmes pratiques comment on va
pas se mentir aux français sous pression
en temps sa confiance est quelque fois
ça va pas ça confortable
j'ai dû à elle à la main sur elle
faisait un joli coup donc ici alors
allez les noirs ou peut-être souffre
aussi peur
drôle de position elle a besoin de plus
mais mais toutes les versions chanson
leurs robes noires voyez donc à voir ce
qui se passe ici c'est un noir de jeux
réussis
concave alliage c'est peut être un
couple avant avec comprend ashes
tourcoing existe dangereux
coiffe ou au sein qui se devrait être
joué pour empêcher cavaliers h6 l'après
foot à 5 photo efe d'essais de l'équipe
est un petit peu les pièces
car faux sacs mal à risque normal
ce que j'ai essayé d'aller regarder
ainsi si je vais aller regarder je vais
je
j'ai décidé de m'occuper de ça ouais
mais je pense que je suis
prochainement ce sera pas mal
j'ai là
j'étais convaincu que je ne sais pas
faire
je n'ai pas trouvé
ah ah ah
elle a là un point sur deux elle a perdu
l'après midi contre
collage qui n'a absolument pas très
facile comme et 11 suite elle a perdu
compères cela l'a gagné entre une 1900
que de pologne
donc pas si facile pour l'instant voilà
donc là je compte qu'une 2100 quelque
chose je crois
ok est-ce qu'on retourne voir nommé il
ya nos hommes mais ça ça sonne un peu
mal ah ouais le championnat mixte je
cherche un modèle mixte les voilà
donc on va au fond n'est peut-être tu
veux sur bastien au concours car 100
carats scène qui a son petit pion de
plus un essai un pion b faisons
symétrique avec un plan b passer ça
devrais je pense faire la paire t'en
penses quoi
qu'est ce que tu penses que ça va gagner
oui oui je pense
f5
je pense que j'ai eu des finales
similaire mais des coups il a craqué
assez vite drief pour un joueur de ce
niveau là mais magnus c'est très très
fort dans ce genre de position il a des
positions comme ça tout le temps pour
appeler un c'était la paire de fou qu'on
se fout cavaliers il y avait un pion de
moi est-ce qu'on peut revoir un tir ipd
de la douzaine de derniers coups ses
fans la mettre en mode saas comme
super
six prises à cette
fin ils avaient affaire de fous ils
étaient en train de travailler cette
position me rappeler on vous avait pour
ces constats qui paie six tours siens y
travaillent
il a regagné son pion de retard et il a
la pression sur le camp adverse
il entre ces tours et il fait mal avec
ses tours aux petits pions à
mais du coup il lit le croûte avec en
plus la septième rangée et la pression
est trop dur
travail et là c'est une finale technique
il a jugé complètement gagnante et
maintenant c'est fait
pourquoi l'afrique il a ça ça va gagner
facilement pour katz pour nous tes pas
et pour 40 sanofi
dont 4,5 non mais là encore on voit
franchement qu'est-ce qui joue bien
c'est la folie champion du monde c'est
tout ce qu'on veut mais c'est à chaque
fois qu'on le voit jouer
c'est un métronome parce que même les
parties qu'il n'a pas gagné aujourd'hui
ou qui n'auraient pu ne pas gagner comme
la première basse il a joué très solide
et si les joueurs en face qui ne craque
pas mais il met une pression de folie qu
à chaque fois est-ce que vous pensez que
même si tu allais même si tu as un
joueur qu'à 26 26 50 avec les blancs
content car c'est là-bas il veut faire
nul en fait et carlson doit s est de
gagner créé noir à chaque fois contre
l'angola et vin blanc
et c'est hyper dur
devant jeu pour le gard à chaque fois
pascal 26 56 hyper fort et quand
vraiment ben
t'as 26,50 suit pas perdre ça va passer
quand même
à tort sur menace de behcet la magnus
gagnerait la balance parce qu'il y
aurait amené chez coca dreyer va faire
froid g63 g7 très ouvre à chis 3g ça ça
se pressait et sur les a pressés faire
rager 7 explique ça empêche en fait la
tour phare échec puis d'alain parce que
je mange de la tour donc là on voit
qu'on pense qu'il va y avoir droit j'ai
six des sept rois gsm
on peut je pense imaginé ce scénario
pour un coût de la partie et
probablement après on ne sait pas
comment comment gagner ça après
peut-être un deux trois voilà parce
qu'il a fait là deux trois ouvrages à 3h
4 pour tenter de ramener de monter un
peu le roi je pense voir un truc comme
ça
oui l'afrique c'est l'adversaire il a
plus qu'à maintenant provoquer un coup
droit là les noirs sont quasiment obligé